[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
trainer cocoona
trainer again and venusaur
wait we're in the game we're in the game
oh [__] juice licker
i don't know dude don't know what to do
mike is throbbing throbbing
did we deserve that game i think we did
did you oh
[Music]
so i've been playing like 50 a day
and it's too soon it's too soon hikaru
we didn't even reach a climax
[Music]
so
hello everybody and welcome back to the
chess.com pogchamps
my name is levi ross and i'm joined
today by andrea botez
and well currently missing in action
very important business meeting grand
master daniel
naredinsky andrea how are you i'm
feeling great how about yourself
i i'm pumped for these games i feel like
today we're gonna get some good
interviews
uh and before we talk specifically about
our matchup why we started early today
let's run you through some logistics
first things first the format we got
four groups of four players
double round robin time format is ten
minutes with five second
motives excuse me uh if you win without
needing an armageddon you get three
points two points otherwise and one
point if you make it to the armageddon
and lose let's talk prizes
andrea i don't know about you but i have
never won
anywhere near this amount of money i'm
always blown away when it gets up on the
screen
uh playing chess yeah i don't think i've
ever even
won money in an online actually twitch
rivals but not even comparable to this
yeah it's a lot of money uh you get a
bonus for winning your group obviously
uh the championship bracket thirty
thousand dollars in prices consolation
16.
let's talk about the schedule uh our
group stage is about halfway done
uh we are now uh i guess five or six
days in with some res days we'll have
the quarterfinals beginning right at the
beginning of september
and then it's just we're running
straight to the finish line
everyday broadcasts begin at 1 p.m
pacific time
with the exception of today because our
first matchup actually was bumped from
yesterday
a little bit forward austin show versus
half door and that is where i will ask
andrea
any predictions well you know this one
is
very difficult to predict i'm gonna take
a wild
guess and assume that thor is gonna be
awesome
even though you know austin has a lot of
experience in the game he's been
training for months and days but
i think thor will be winning today how
about you what do you think
i i think it's gonna be i think it's
gonna be a bloody battle
i think i think austin's gonna come out
swinging uh
just like you know conor mcgregor did in
that in that video against uh
against thor um as far as that matchup
goes
i just want to see austin just you know
show show some improvement from last
time it's not even a dig at austin it's
just good to see
you know like it it'll be good to see
him like practicing
improving his game has been playing a
lot of chess you gave him how many
lessons
oh yeah i did teach him before pog
champs but they were mostly like
impromptu matches like workout slash
chess matches but he was pretty strong a
few months ago too
so like physically or you know both on
the board and obviously physically
yeah uh we already we see him live it's
a beautiful chair by the way
i feel like that chair i feel like that
chair weighs like 200 pounds i feel like
he doesn't sit in it he just curls it
it has a very nice game of thrones vibes
i wonder if it's on purpose or not
he's i think he's also in a new spot he
must have moved
right and he has his name on his shirt
all right haven't seen that one yet
yeah everybody keeps telling me to make
merch probably the same as the same
uh the same is the same the same can be
said for you and alexandra i don't know
if i would make it gotham and just put
it on my shirt
be like yeah i wouldn't like wearing my
own name on my shirt but
you know thor's name is short and simple
it fits well on the shirt
um i think
well we've just about covered every
single bit of the logistics um we've got
games beginning in just a second and i
think daniel naradiski has arrived
so let's take a quick break let's get
daniel
and we'll uh be ready to go sounds good
all right thor seems nervous
i am a bit nervous you know i want to do
well
i want to i don't do well guys
that's the thing you know i want to do
well
i need to get comfortable
get comfortable i [__] put some water
on me god damn it
[Music]
i see some skinny
bro i promise you guys if you would
stand next to me
you would not say that i look skinny i
just look skinny compared to
[Music]
uh usual usually i'm a beast now i'm a
mini beast i'm a mini beast now
the fight is next year september i'm
going to lose a lot of weight before
that fight
i'm doing a lot of currency right now
doing
a lot more endurance work so of course
i'm losing
some weight that's normal i guess
am i like what's going on is the maths
not
going on or like what the [__]
happening guys uh hey guys if you can
hear us we're supposed to be competing
i wanna let you know we have a slight
delay we'll be starting in about three
minutes
how long did you say three minutes okay
and then i'm in the right spot right
chess.com live
yeah you're good i just checked you and
the half thor are both
ready to go okay cool
thanks thanks
all right uh i'm ready let's see i'm
gonna take this
off take this headphones off
all right i gotta stay focused guys i
gotta stay
focused right now in this match i'm not
gonna talk to anyone i'm just gonna stay
focused hey i'm gonna um do my
i don't think you are oh
because it just said join right breakout
room i click join button
can i listen
[Music]
and back with us we have the man the
myth of legend the prophet
grandmaster daniel nerdscape what a is
that like of
any nickname you could have dreamed up
for yourself is that like at the top
it i would have never dreamed you know
it's you can't script it any better
um you just you never know how your life
turns and
uh obviously i love it um i'm totally
behind it i'm not sure i can live up to
that name for very much longer but
you know if you need any moves predicted
you know just turn to me
and uh you know i gotta try to keep it
up
uh i don't think you are going to be
doing
much predicting this game that's
all i have to say all the great people i
saw austin's show i really wish
uh austin would would stream these games
because this production is incredible
um but well guys predictions
what are we gonna get austin show half
door andrea
dania openings middle games how long is
the first game gonna last
a great question i'd say
no more than five minutes
for game one minutes
yes i'd say half the time
well i'm thinking i'm gonna say i think
more than five minutes i think it's
going to be decided
let me go on an alum here in an end game
i'm going to say pull out your varetsky
and game manual because i think they're
going to an end game
well we're about to find out what's good
in the opening uh
mountain's got the white pieces he's a
king spawn player there it is
awesome looking very serious and focused
he's crowning his eyebrows
he's a as intimidating as thor today
that look
guys do you think thor is going to go
for oh the oh there
no there's not going to be anything yeah
there's not going to be any f7 stuff
wow he's not falling for any tricks
someone maybe took some advice or
like some coaching guys whoa
did austin work with someone between e5
this is like this is cutting edge theory
this is carlson vegeta grove
oh my god wait whoa whoa whoa whoa half
door what's he doing
this should be three not a great move
allowing d takes e4
wait what did i tell you about that end
game oh no no he doesn't see it
yeah i wonder if austin prepared his
opening but maybe
wow uh dad could have gotten real bad
real quick
oh this is not no no no no no no this is
not
wow well he's over protecting the e4
pawn
i mean he's playing according to you
know the great
forefather positional chess aaron
nimsovich oh i thought you were gonna
say
daniel narrative escape no me and
positional chess they
they don't mix very well
guys weakening the king side i don't
like this thor
has been playing differently
during pawn champs than when he normally
plays
i don't think he's i've ever seen him
play the move f3 i think he's usually
very confident taking pieces you know
getting kind of to the
bones of the position but not you know
even a
yeah that's exactly what i was going to
say too normally his openings are a
little bit more solid
f3 like a huge weakness now on that
diagonal
so i don't know if the pressure is
getting to him which i wouldn't expect
to happen to thor but
he is playing a little bit differently
yeah
f3 also takes away a crucial development
square for the night here we see austin
knight h5 preparing
h4 check
i don't actually think if that's
actually the idea
i will be floored if he actually plays
so will i no austin must have done some
serious preparation i didn't think he
did any but
with his play so far i'm very impressed
the fact that he's thinking though tells
me that knight h5 he was dreaming up a
different idea than queen h4 but maybe
he'll find it
so far austin is playing like a super
grand master
knight h5 was even the best move as long
as he finds queen h4 but
it's such an unnatural move you know
because your opponent just took a pawn
here
uh you want to move a bishop yourself
because they've just moved the bishop
and you go wait a second
maybe i can bring my bishop or continue
with my plan of bringing in the knight
indeed and taking his time here is
austin now he could also just develop
his bishop for example to c5 that
wouldn't be that bad
stopping away from castling but this is
a critical moment
in the early going for sure i think if
he's oh
never mind oh okay i was about to speak
too soon
he's repeating the same mistake that
thor did
wow wow wow yeah well i guess you know
you say he did it so i can do it
but it's a little different you know in
terms of also
physical capabilities as well uh let's
check in with thor
let's check in with dorsey what he's up
to
all right what's going on all right
buddy
some noises he's doing some asmr he's
always making noises
i can be the falsetto to his you know
this is this i'm gonna be the i'm gonna
be the true setto
okay oh is he munching on something
big oh i got it oh falsetto oh my god
that was that was the best pun ever made
i was waiting for somebody
i'm sorry i didn't get it done
unacceptable
oh god thor come on i believe in him to
see
those threads what do you think he's
eating yeah i was gonna ask that i
really have no idea it's gray
and doesn't have much to it it looks
like a lobster right now when he took
that one bite of it
i'm surprised they didn't eat it in one
bite honestly it kind of looked like
beach sand like glued together but i
don't want to question anything he's
eating you know
whatever it is it's working because he
just took the rook
pure protein brain food
and he's taken on g8
i love that you can hear his munching
noises too he's really giving us a full
asmr show here this is great i mean
we are talking over the asmr show we
were going to peep in and he's
he is just whoa that's a big i mean that
was a large whatever it is he's eating
he just
took a large one of those you know i
uploaded my lesson uh with half thor
like onto you know i have like this
playlist of like of like pog chance
lessons
some guy was like criticized like how
dare he eat
and then like people had a discussion
like you know he's the world's strongest
man he's gotta consume like
you know 20 000 calories a day or
something like that long comment thread
cracked me up
he's not going to eat during a lesson
what is that who would have thought
eating durian away
unacceptable by the way he's actually
not speaking right i don't have him
muted
i don't believe he is no no he's just
munching
yeah he must consume
and look at that bishop just vacuuming
up
everything in its path yeah he's
vacuuming that snack just like he's
vacuuming up the buns
that bishop's doing some heavy lifting
getting my drift there that's a double
pun
dad yeah yeah this is this is the
content that i'm here for we got we got
puns we got
uh i think i saw i think that was i saw
alexandra say that's my student
what did she say she was cheering on um
he was cheering on austin austin was
playing very well knight h5 was actually
a brilliant move
i know i was i was so disappointed queen
h4 would have been fantastic no one
would have expected this play from
austin
indeed austin showing impeccable
preparation but
that bishop is not really a thorn in
black side
uh now there's supposed to be laughter
that ensues from the two of you
um i i'm not accepting this this gloom
and dude can't tell when they're jokes
was that a joke a thorn in black's
well thorn and austin's showing you know
it's better these are like the easiest
last names to plan with though
oh okay did you prepare this or are you
doing this on the fly africa
that's almost as good as my dad's jokes
that's
they're not half as good as he does jeff
yeah that was
sarcasm oh my god i don't even
well yeah that one flew by me i
apologize i didn't even
well what's not flowing by thor is all
of black spawns in all black's pieces
which he said yeah i think thor is just
slowly gonna
take all of austin's pieces
well i haven't made my prediction and i
predict now that we have 12 moves on the
board
that this is not decided in an end game
or within five minutes i predict it goes
about 25 moves and then there might be
some sort of checkmate opportunity
or he'll just play a3 see thor just
needs to go for it
like a3 is such a respectful move
right bishop g6 check they're picked off
the knight on h5 but that's not really
going anywhere
yeah what is the what is the actual
fastest way that you can
you can win i mean bishop g6 is good
it's about getting this queen in the
game right you gotta get the queen on d1
in the game
right and black's maybe only source of
counter player now is a check on c5
maybe push the king to the corner on h1
there's some mating patterns there with
a potential knight appearing on g3
i think that's way way in the future i
don't think that's going to happen
yeah that would be genius oh well this
is helping up opening the h
file maybe this plan will even work
better guys do you think we're going to
get knight g3 hg3 bishop c5 king h1
queen h6 we're all looking at that right
chad yes i think he'll take the knight
but i don't know if he'll see oh never
mind
i was wrong well he's centralizing his
knight he's centralized let's give him
that
forgetting about the other one that's
hanging but you know he was a dead
knight anyway
he's adhering to positional principles
centralizing his pieces except he might
not have any pieces left pretty soon
that is a good point
so still bishop c5 loading up that uh
what do you call those medieval weapons
like those trebuchet i think
loading up the trebuchet never heard of
those but they sound fancy
what you've never heard of a trebuchet
really no
no idea what oh my gosh are they from
movies or
well i used to play this game age of
empires um and
i loved creating trebuchets and like
shooting them at
the enemy's castle is that is that
something you can admit publicly that
you played one of those games
i don't know well now that i think about
it maybe i should have
held off on that yeah wait i'm waiting
to see the cherry oh no the
chat seems hype okay never mind it's
okay it's like people receptive to
yeah okay i was kind of obsessed with
that game even i think even before chess
wow wait for real have you ever thought
about streaming it
wow i was trying to find
the old version that i used to play uh
the retro version
i could totally stream that i'm i was
pretty good at it actually
there it is uh that's the
trebuchet uh-huh well there is no
trebuchet here c6 is
more like a rock that you throw out the
castle far from a trebuchet
it's not even reaching the castle it
just fell in a pond far
away all right thor is coming
there's the rook great move and he's
just got rook takes pawn coming
he's got to get his queen in the game
he's not going to be able to deliver a
checkmate right away
with just the rook but it's hard for him
to get the queen because he plays
queenie too
that would just get taken and
yeah i mean austin just needs a i think
one or two more filler chess lessons and
he'll be i mean he'll be more than okay
i'm curious what his plan was with
pushing c6
it was the last pawn that hadn't moved
so that one got a turn
they're great everyone that has to be
fair you get a pawn push you get a fun
push all right
he's about justice here i get it yes
can't leave any pawns out
of course forget about the minor pieces
and the
the rooks and queens might as well start
with the pawns
indeed indeed so levy and andrea what
were your first ratings do you remember
your first ratings
yes you remember yours i i played my
first tournament when i was like
six but i don't remember it at all
so i had a i had a fun tournament
experience because
growing up like uh the ratings are
really weird you know if you have a
really good first tournament you get an
absurdly high rating right that's what
happens
so my first tournament i played some you
know under section i fried liver a few
people i i get a few easy wins
i go four and oh i'm like 800 like yo
dad sign me up for that under 1 000
section we gonna clap it
magnus invitational yeah i was literally
get me in pod shams bro we went in
second tournament i play i forgot how to
notate i was so nervous
i lost all my games all my games
i'm surprised you're even notating on
your second tournament pretty impressive
though right
exactly yeah that already is my dad made
a deal he's like i'm only taking you to
tournaments if you're gonna get better
you know you're not just for fun because
they were expensive like my dad did the
same
yeah yeah daniel what about you like
1300 first rate
i was i was actually 803 and
my brother was 1294 and i was incredibly
i can admit to that now i was so jealous
it was actually not even funny i was
803. i actually
during my first tournament i i remember
that i played one
um kid who recorded the results before
the game was over because i was down
like 50 pieces
kind of like austin is here and i was so
angry i'm like
one day i am going to show this kid
who's the boss and of course i never
played him again
oh my gosh i remember the name of the
opponent who i got really scared against
and i was like hey
how do you write castling again and he
looked at me and he was like
oh oh and i was like all right sorry
yeah kids were mean they were
that was always intimidated by my
opponents
yeah there is a camp that i teach at
every year called castle chess camp
and one of the kids um during one of the
sessions was like so are you teaching at
ooo camp next year
i looked at him what do you mean oh oh
cam and it took me about 30 minutes but
then later i realized
oh oh stands for castle he had actually
made a pun
i actually didn't understand the fun can
you believe that yeah
it's okay because now you're the pun
master so you made up for it
wow oh oh oh wow i got it
that's really i'm slow with puns i'm
really really slow
yeah i always get every single pun can't
relate levy
you know what half thor is not slow with
taking black's pieces
yeah he's been killing it he used that
file right away push
it's pretty close coming for his king
already
it is plus 34 and it's really plus 34
because the engine that we have
only goes to depth 16 if you get like
depth 20 on this thing
it'll yeah i think what's gonna is he
gonna take with the queen he's gotta
move the queen he hasn't moved the queen
yet what do you mean you
can't play a chess game no no not you
well there is a chance he moves his king
can happen oh no no all right queen
sacrifices itself for the greater good
king has to take he's gotta at least
move two more pieces and then his goal
for the game is done
are you sure he set goals for this game
i i set him a goal okay okay got it
got it let me clarify something if one
of the sides
has no pieces is it like a half end game
or is it can it still be called an end
game
but the other side has all of their but
black doesn't have any pieces left so
technically does it fit the category of
an end game
we could say austin made it to the end
game that is that is an accomplishment
block with the bishop if he blocks with
the bishop i will be so happy
i will be happy as well yep
bring all the toys to the nursery party
he can
also give white a check actually 92
check at least he can say he gave what a
check no no he moves all right
no bishop half tour should not play
queen e6 here like he needs to find a
way to get his queen in successfully
and you do that by playing queen e5
which hits the rook
runs check on g7 h8 f6 d6
every square basically
and oh wow oh that's nice good move
best move mate in five mate in five yep
i totally saw that
and that's what that's with most
resilient defense
yes come on rook b7
probably let's try to predict the move
what do you think is gonna oh wow
he saw it good defense he's he has lots
of potential like he sees
some of these tactics will he see the
bishop though on h7 if he plays
he will he's got it
cool he does austin move your bishop on
c8 please
it's sad poor guy only has a minute 30
seconds
oh almost two more squares he's so close
maybe he's preparing rook takes f3 after
gf knight takes after he wins the queen
right yes he saw rook f3 gf3 knight f3
but he didn't see rook h7 that's totally
logical levy
guys is how much we're gonna find queen
queen mate
i think thor is gonna find it let's see
we could uh listen in
i think he's going to play bishop h6 but
we'll see oh my god oh wow
prophet i can't believe it
i don't know if we were gonna we could
we could listen in let's see it's gonna
be
gg very soon but here's thought process
or none there's one move
in between i take you're right
he sees it what he thought it was
[Music]
seriously both players playing without
pieces rook and bishop
everything's fully in stock and
everything looks delicious
exactly yep if i go
here
i can see myself losing on time here
his calculation process is pretty solid
too
because calculating at least three moves
ahead
the rook is coming
oh never mind he doesn't know which
piece to grab he's got so many extra
pieces
he's grabbing all of them
he literally is at f6 is a great move
i'm just gonna be more hooking the game
i finished this off
he wants to give every piece of trans
skirt bro if you play knight b5 i'm
gonna flip out
the idea of the show there's so many
good moves
they just can't decide oh
or is he just i think he's sort of
stream of consciousness kind of thing
going on
yeah he thinks out loud i haven't met
max volume and i thought
oh why is he hiding underneath his hands
is he embarrassed what does he yeah what
is his thinking pose
he's like if i look at the position with
one eye maybe like i can find some other
moves
all right we're back ah
this is uh
i have a question if the bishop gets
captured on c8 does it count like austin
used all his pieces
uh i'd say no because he never moved it
right
but then again he probably didn't move
other pieces that are off the board
right now
i don't think i have i think he yeah
other than the bishop right he moved
every piece oh it got taken
stay all made except could have been a
nice stalemate if you didn't have those
pawns
well if he didn't at least he wouldn't
well he'd have been
yeah if they're blocked i don't think
i've ever seen a situation where players
up
four pieces of rook and a queen why
didn't i have those games
you and i have had a few games like that
in hyperbole
yeah that's true in 10 seconds you know
feel as though that was that was a good
win i mean
mountain actually no that wasn't that
wasn't
a perfect win his opening was shaking
austin did have a very good position the
first like seven eight moves
yeah thor's opening was not the best
while austin was very strong in the
beginning just
missed that one key move
yeah teenage four was was was smashing
so
i know i shouldn't criticize i know i
know
everything's fine there's no one behind
me the other day there was a giant
yellow jacket in my house that was
terrible
oh god i'm terrified of those things i
would not be able to commentate
austin typed in the chat i don't know
how to win
well knight h5 that's an indicator of
talent
that talent needs to be fleshed out but
if that's not talent then i don't know
what it is
he had a good intuition for the
beginning he had him in the first half
you know that's what they say
honestly he got us half done honestly he
did if he just gets his his bishops out
castles is king he's gonna be all right
he's gonna be all right
i'm excited to see what opening they're
gonna play with white this time
is uh austin yeah i know
i know austin also generally gets very
nervous in his matches
um so i wonder if also the fact that
he's playing against thor
increases his nerves or anything but he
did look very nervous i was just looking
at him a minute ago
the thing is that like when you are so
successful
at what you do something like chess is
really it's really off-putting because
oftentimes it deconstructs like
everything you knew about whatever it
was that you were doing it's a video
game a sport
you know he runs like an extremely
extremely successful show so
chess just sucks like it's so brutal
when you start out
right yeah you have nothing to grab onto
yeah like true like seriously uh it's it
can be really really tough
but it takes hours and hours of practice
the next game i'm trying to conquer is
fall guys oh i'm also on that road
have you gone to crown yet i've played
like 20 games so
i mean not yet okay don't worry i've
played like a hundred and i
haven't gotten one yet either so talk to
me when you stream for like 16 hours and
don't win that's
oh i did i did exactly that don't worry
my sister and i we were like okay we're
gonna end stream once we won it was like
seven hours later
we did that a few days in a row so
definitely put in more than 16 hours
oh wow oh wow oh wow all right oh
we have kind of the same well we have
e45 knight c3 the vienna game
this is interesting this is cutting edge
theory now you know there's different uh
instances of bishop c4
knight f3 when it's better to play one
move versus the other
a lot of grand masters they opt for c6
and knight f6 when you play bishop c4
what is austin going to play here as
long as he doesn't push that pawn i'm
happy
yeah that's a move that well queen g4
here is actually i think
one of the theoretical ones knight f3
though he seems very well coached in the
opening i mean his
first couple moves are solid and uh
basically the best moves in the position
and again mountain is doing some weird
stuff guys
yeah he doesn't really follow most
opening principles but he does
that's the thing when he plays he does
so what's going on it's the pressure
but i don't even know how laura would
wave under pressure ladies and gentlemen
rook g1
what a that is a very subtle move he is
going for the king side attack g4
g5 um
now knight d5 there was very good
attacking the queen instead yes
that was the move that actually would
have put uh half door in a difficult
situation
which he's playing on all fronts here
guys he's he's attacking on the queen
set and on the kings i think half thor's
just gonna resign he's this is too
overwhelming
i remember go ahead andre oh yeah i was
gonna say
austin calculated this out by knowing
that thor moved his queen early he knew
he was gonna kingside castle so it was
all planned
right king attack yes he had done a
lesson with his coach
on the fact that you can let your
opponent commit their king to a side of
the board exactly
and then play g4 h4 and a4 has a long
a long-term idea of playing rook a3
clearing out the third rank
and getting a rook on to g3 right a
mastermind plan there let me ask the two
of you another question
oh you know that when rook f1
repositioning is
castling except the king's only one i
was gonna say
you know when beginners start off play
chess they play a4 and rook a3
why do beginners have a tendency to move
their pawns is it that they're afraid to
move their central pawns why is there
this instinct
i think they just like pushing their
pawns in general i remember when i'd
play against when i was a younger kid
everyone would just go
a4 b4 c4 everything so
interesting um my my scholastic students
from my program were
all well equipped and you know
cutting-edge night or theory uh poison
pawn variation
uh sometimes taiman of you know o'kelly
to mix it up but
uh other times you have berlin why
didn't they play
i mean any self-respecting coach
especially from new york should teach
their students to sveshnikov
i know but we were getting a lot of
rossolimo you know so we wanted to
avoid okay wait guys i have a serious
question
do you think austin knows how to castle
he just said in the chat he was trying
to castle i don't think he does
no that's why he probably thought like
rook g1 would somehow switch spots with
his king
and then he gave it a second try with
rook f1
just that's like me trying to tie a tie
or something you just like
you know throw it around just hope it
materializes yeah it actually never does
yes i haven't had to tie a tie in a
while they're all just tied in my like
in in the closet already i just put them
on because otherwise it's just like uh
okay let's try that again um
yeah so he's only got one way to defend
this queen well a few but yes the block
is essentially the way see if you'll
find it
i have a bad feeling he might take that
but sure no he does
okay good move i like it
h5 keeping it's keeping the pin i'd say
maybe he could manual castle but the
problem is the bishop on c5 he's never
going to get that diagonal
for white knight f5 here attacking the
queen would be a very sensible move but
austin's got to find a way to
disentangle his pieces here he's really
tangled up
disentangle you got puns and vocabulary
you learned that on bigwords.com as well
i did big words.com big sponsor of chess
indeed indeed all right austin's
defending his knight
he's being a little bit cautious here um
decent instincts
g3 and f3 is very interesting because
because he also has knight f5
which is a very legitimate idea
definitely
i don't know if you will see knight f5
though
yeah and after thinking about what to do
he can take the pawn on e4 he can keep
developing
very complicated position
but again if he did like two
hours of just training he'd be
he'd be super his openings wouldn't be
bad and a lot of it is confidence a lot
of it is you you
arrive at the board and you're like i'm
going to lose i have no idea what i'm
doing i'm just going to play moves
whereas chess is so much about
confidence
so much about confidence like you have
to believe in the fact that you're going
to win the game or the match
before you get there and so he just
needs a little bit of that he'll be fine
hide a2 you think he's going to go b4
next
maybe brooke b1 that'd be a good play i
think
maybe he thought he saw that oh 92 would
be
blocking his queen and taking space from
his king maybe he has a good
thought process here let's go let's go
watch some half door asmr
that's what i want to see right now
sounds great
i would love some have to raise some
more
breathing heavily
oh wow
this is quality content i'm very happy
too intense why
i feel like he's breathing abnormally
fast
maybe not maybe not this is
this is good why is he is huffing and
puffing
i think he's just saying something i
don't think he's saying anything if he's
saying something i'm
terrified right that fire will come out
oh
the breathing intensifies his nose is
literally i think he's eating his
microphone
his nose is literally chilling on the
mic
protein pancakes weren't good enough he
needs to eat the whole mic
yeah next thing we see you're just gonna
gobble up the entire mic
uh
also went back to rook g1 that's a
pretty
you know what i like he hasn't blundered
everything is solid that's
true that's a great point and rook g1
was a pretty great move maybe he
actually is going for the king attack
or he's just making his king
yeah it's not easy to make a move here
for black like i mean there's many
solid moves okay an mp6 is decent
all right let's let's go back to the big
board we can leave
we can leave the audio on for after
right he's not going to say anything
he'll just be breathing the entire time
no
we don't have to do that that's that's
gonna be chaos uh knight b6
that attacks the a4 pawn
do you guys think austin will go for the
king side attack
or is he gonna get distracted by thor's
last move on the queen side
i mean i think he's going to go maybe a5
or like b3
a5 would be a decent move except it
wouldn't c4
but it's a good try b4 maybe
it's 13 moves in and the position is in
the balance the eval bar
i know is a little bit uh in mountain's
favor
that's just because he's breathing very
hard and scaring it but normally it
would be
closer to about equal well i think he's
going to eat the barf soon it might
disappear from our board
i've heard it's high in protein that's
this is so nice
this is definitely one of austin's best
games even though he played the opening
very strange and wasted a lot of time
with his rook
his position is not too bad so he's gone
c3 actually defending the pawn on a4
very nice oh actually no d takes c3
exposes the rook on g1
yeah that is that's tough to see uh
afterward takes but does he see bishop
guys
austin was calculating he was seeing
that queen
defense but he missed that bishop wow
look at the speed with which thor took
that those protein pancakes were
definitely not enough
yeah he's looking for more that's the
second time
that's actually this if you guys
remember in the first game bishop c4
took g8
and we got bishop c5 austin is repeating
the same mistake
so that is just something you know a
long-range bishop attack
he took it instantly he saw it all that
comes from his experience
um i also just realized that
i didn't have to remute it this entire
time on my computer
he just said a word he had not spoken in
five minutes
he said all right
[Music]
is he slapping himself i think he's uh
finally
he was very serious deep breathing but
now he's cooled down a little bit
he's talking relaxed he just leaned back
because he won that rook you can tell
he's feeling a little bit better
oh and oh f4 is somewhat unfortunate
and there goes the queen i've told you
he was singing
he's actually singing he not yet he
hasn't taken it just yet but
it's the same distance right there's
three squares in between the queen in
the rand yeah he he does smarter
so i did say that austin had not
blundered and that's just the difficulty
of a closed position your
all your pieces are locked together and
the second you create an opening
bishop long range piece just comes
straight down pawn moves up
door opens for the other bishop and uh
looks like it's going to be 2-0 indeed
he takes f4 here would be sensible
which he does wow excellent technique
here displayed by half thor
this is this is difficult
that all you can eat buffet you
mentioned the plates are starting to get
stocked up
94 yeah another good move yeah i mean
this was a pretty tough matchup for
austin
yeah so
i know austin's got one more matchup
wait is that a matchup against
oh no um let's see
i really hope not it is it is oh
oh austin couple hours of coaching
oh man but wagon mama is even stronger
than thor
on the board of course uh maybe i mean
it's the
the you know physical strength is
debatable the chess board yeah
what what if we do like a crowd effort
we do like
chat votes when austin plays against
wagner so like austin doesn't play his
game pretty much then
listen austin is in
in this bracket it like in this group
group d i don't know if we have like the
full standings but in group d we we've
got wagamamo who is
in my opinion the strongest player in
the event uh not a lot of people are
talking about it because halfway has
been doing a lot of lessons a lot of
training but
uh wow this is about to be checkmated in
two queens
flawless technique by malcolm just do a
cross what was that
he looks very puzzled oh okay we're
deciding
to just uh you know chill a little bit
take a couple more pawns
yeah yeah like austin and connor will
get another chance in the consolation
bracket
so that is true that's probably he's
praying
but i don't even know what he's praying
for here no no no
he's hovering where the c3 square no way
okay come on no thor won't beat his
gambit here
he's doing that thing where he's
touching all his pieces again sorry
he got it i was just gonna say
he likes to taste them all andrea and
alexandra have to
have you know do an intervention with
with austin and just be like listen
we got a chance at redemption in the
consolation bracket
let's go it's going to be the biggest
redemption arc
of 2020 i agree we'll have to convince
austin to do some lessons because i know
my sister tried one and they just got
distracted and like talked about
piloting for about a few hours but at
least she taught him the pieces
that lesson so what wait about
a flight simulator yeah cause austin i
think
he has some piloting experience like
real life
really simulator wow yeah it's his
favorite hobby
and he actually i did the first um i
think it was a flight simulator stream
but that's exciting for him because he's
finally doing he is his first time doing
solo content
that is very cool there's a lot of mates
okay he just goes for the ladder
yep that actually is very cool i mean
piloting is awesome that night knight d1
there is
still queen v2 by the way you'd like a
fancy checkmate
well uh congratulations
to the mountain uh i think we are going
to do
our usual break after the games are over
see whether both players or one of them
will be joining us to talk with us
about the games life piloting and
whatnot
don't go anywhere short break we'll be
right back with interviews
saying that i don't get nervous very
often
i got very nervous a couple of times on
stream obviously do you find these
puzzles help a lot i've never done these
before
it's fiance yeah well there it doesn't
matter what it is anyway
one of the trickiest end games to play
early game hearthstone she was best
player if i remember correctly
black this is one of the trickiest end
games to play black has one
move that can save the game move your
king into the square
of move your king into the square of the
pawn
[Music]
um
okay it's a villa jersey for good luck i
don't know
i just we went very official last time
with the bow ties so this time we just
decided to dress down a little bit
play warm up rank 100 to 600 possibility
to increase your speed what's that
i don't know what it is we've never done
these challenges before
okay so we gotta we gotta stop him
going up here what is the what is the
best way
one two three four one two three four i
guess it's gonna be that way right
where's it gonna be one two three
no [__]
oh we're under the chest.com stream we
got that wrong no
they're going to know they're going to
know that we're going to lose now no
why didn't i do these before
the pawns going down the square rule
what i have no idea i need the box to
king out i don't know
say hi to the big screen gangster and
good luck what's up levy how are you
doing
welcome to the people over there i've
just embarrassed
myself because i don't know how to do
this basic end game but it's all part of
it's all part of the plan it's all part
of the plan
it's all part of the plan all right so
if we go here
the king maybe can stop me from going
where i need to go if we go here
i don't know catch the pawn i'm trying
to catch
the pawn i've never done this before
they've only ever showed me how to win
the game they never showed me how to
save the game
the pawns going the other way
how am i meant to know that
why didn't they tell me all right well
then it's obviously here yeah all right
all right everybody calm down
the squares are labeled what do you mean
the squares are labeled hey anyone
watching the chess channel
relax all right we got this we're just
just a little bit entertainment for you
guys
you had the right idea you got this
first comment i saw on the chest stream
was no way xqc beats the shiro nerd i
did look like a euro nerd
i don't know if that i don't know if the
headband is what we should be rocking
one eight a h i do do you understand as
someone who's new to chess
how hard it is to understand the
notation
it makes sense now i look at it because
when you're down to send to the board it
goes like abcd blah blah blah
but how pathetic is it that i cut off
saying a to h i didn't even complete it
but when i was doing the stream with
levy
and jen and they were just like g5
e4 c2 and that's like obviously they're
doing a lot quicker and a lot more moves
i was like what is going on jerk village
says the carriage just said he thinks
both of you will be in the champion
bracket nice way to jinx me to karu
nice way to put the pressure on of
course this was the right way all right
everybody calm down
everybody relax we've never done this
before white pawn
move wins the game for white we're going
this way right
everybody we are going this way and i
don't see why we just go here
i'm pretty sure we should go here
no i don't get to run it all the way up
the board come on
[Music]
so
what's that in pounds yeah pounds well
is 400 pounds so a little bit less than
400 i'm still so as you guys can see he
had a huge size advantage
in this match i mean it just wasn't even
fair from the beginning
really um yeah
so you know it's okay austin you have
the the hair advantage
because i know you're always worried
about your hair but it was on point
today
thank you so it must have made you feel
good thank you at least something was on
point
uh today uh you know we're gonna have to
off the go it wasn't my best performance
i'm gonna have to go look at the tape
and uh you know see what went wrong uh
you know as far as i'm aware about
everything went wrong
um you know stupid effing mistake
actually
your first game was going pretty well
like we thought you prepared
opening there did you do a preparation
oh you did i did i prepared an opening
but i
i i don't know what happened i didn't
prepare the finish
what happened i am very much
uh team austin i i've been i've been
saying if you get
[__] don't say that levy why would you
say that
he can get away with that because i'm
not gonna win so it's he's
get away with him he can get away with
that that's that's something in
in every other component you know but
anyway go on i was just saying like
obviously i've played i've played uh
i coached after a couple times uh he's
done
a lot of lessons with everybody and also
he's played chess in the past so
i'm just saying if you get like like two
good hours
maybe a third if you're up for it uh
with the beautiful sisters
like you'll be you'll be a beast i mean
you'll be like top two top three in the
consolation bracket
yeah i i think uh yeah i i i did i
it was very valuable the 30 minutes that
i spent with uh
alexandra was very valuable i learned
what the pieces were
um and where they moved uh and then my
uh
knowledge sort of stopped and i forgot
how to castle so
um austin wasn't that less than like
three hours
it was a three-hour lesson yes um i i it
just felt like 30 minutes it just blew
by
well i think the chess only was 30
minutes and then you guys just got a
little bit distracted
yeah we were talking to work on that
well and also i want to
i want to correct the record here i get
a lot of flack for my 285 score but i
want to make it known
that that score was drawn down because i
had to play alexandra
for the tied laundry trials repeatedly
okay
so that's why the score is as low as it
was okay well you know you know
uh when we do speed runs we can ask for
a reset rating
so maybe you just you know you see what
they say i mean worse comes to worse
they say no but
i also pay for that half thor
welcome uh congratulations uh
i was going to ask you how come you play
a little bit differently in the opening
during pogchamps than you usually do
because you play kind of timid you
some setups aren't optimal what's what's
going on
i i feel like i i do uh what i
usually do i try to uh castle quickly i
try to push my
pawn up where my king is uh it's called
the italian move or something i can
remember the name of it
yeah yeah and yeah i feel like
i've been doing that in the past um
yeah he was a dirty player
unbelievable dirty
dirty do we want to go over the the
first game where thor
pushed f3 and austin had that brilliant
night move
with his queen yes gentlemen uh you
might see it on the live board i don't
know if you have it open
uh but move six knight h5
from austin was a brilliancy
uh this was a very deep move
yes i really i really dug deep for that
move you know and
uh really came with a lot of forethought
and uh foresight
he just forgot to follow up right yeah
he you know he faked the he faked the
shot but then he didn't he didn't yeah
did not follow through it was actually a
very nice idea
um but so
yeah you know i've talked to both of you
uh about
separately at least about positioning in
terms of the brackets
your next matchup can start with uh
half tour you are going up i think
against connor
sorry i'm just laughing at the idea
often you're going up against the
computer
austin you're not the only one you're
going we can actually not find a
opponent as bad to put you up against um
[Laughter]
anyway go on sorry no no i was just
gonna say uh
after as of now what is your goal in the
uh
in the event i mean i i think we'll see
you in championship bracket
you know you're going to win the entire
thing do you want to call out anybody
should we talk anybody
i i want to well firstly
you know it's just an honor to you know
be a part of this
event um exactly i'm just here to have
fun and do my best you know
obviously i want to win each and every
game i am going to do my best in each
and every game
i know there's a lot of talented people
that are playing
so if i want to be able to win i have to
keep practicing keep getting
classes with these amazing people that
have been so
uh helpful um and you just just keep
grinding basically because like i feel
there's a lot to improve
uh i'm i'm still every single day
making blunders you know
making mistakes so there's a lot to
improve and
and i want to improve and i want to i
want to get better and and hopefully
you know if i'm able to improve um
enough i'll i'll take it all all the way
that was so wholesome yeah that was that
was great oh my god i was like trying to
divvy up how much time i was about to
give austin for a final word
um well austin you got the floor for
like 15 seconds before we put up the
next matchup card what do you got to say
to your next opponent wagamama the
perennial
all i can say is best of luck to you i'm
going to put in a hard training session
thor
it's an absolute pleasure to lose to you
and best of luck for the rest of the
competition
thank you we'll hit the gym sometime
absolutely any time
okay there you go all right well let's
pull up uh
the player cards uh we obviously
have is the most
popular way to describe it the right way
or the most
talked about or is that is that kind of
the same thing hafu
everyone i see chat up in arms saying
huffle's the favorite she gonna take it
down
easy with aces we've got that coming up
and i think we're gonna take a quick
break get the
get both of them loaded up uh and we'll
be back when when their game starts
perfectly either what's that say don't
get
forked do diagonal notice diagonal
all right we need to go to the bathroom
real quick
um i'll be back in a sec
i'm just going to pause we're going to
do you know what you know what as if
we're going in as if we're going in
time for us what up what up
[Applause]
all right we're having a little rave i'm
going to the bathroom
when we come back we go over the rules
one more time and then you've got about
four minutes before it's in emote only
mode and you're not going to be able to
say anything else
and i'm going to be closing the only
thing i'm going to open is my emails in
case poker
starts in case jess i can't do anything
can't contact me so knock yourself out
can we make it later why are you so
[Music]
quiet
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready
not yet but the way she's going she
probably could be to be honest
wanda dubs right what do i need to do
do i need to do anything on chess.com i
just need to make sure
everything's closed i'm in live chess
gotta close the stream oh we're on the
stream the stream's having a rave with
me
hello all right two minutes and it's
gonna be an emote only mode
[Music]
we're playing the irish gun but don't
tell hafu
[Music]
um
have you ever seen hitch and he tries to
go for the first kiss he whips out the
inhaler
i'm just a little bit i just feel a
little nervous now
welcome back everybody to our second
match of the day uh although this one
my friends is kind of like the main
event
would we say what do you guys think i
would definitely say this is the main
event is very close competition
both players have been training a long
time for this
i mean hafu is entering legend lore
um with her grinding but um easy with
aces
absolutely far from a pushover this is
going to be a marquee matchup talked
about matchup
i think it's going to be epic yes it is
going to be epic
uh and this is this is group b
and in group b we have hafu who has been
on the grind who has had uh her main
account
the whole lore with the other account
not being hers but belonging to super
grand master
uh peter svidler and gary kasparov all
this crazy stuff
uh and then you've got david pakman
you've got easy with aces and you've got
xuc
so it's like a very intriguing group of
people who are all doing different
things
on stream and well i feel as though
david pakman was like the first attempt
at cracking the armor
and he got close very close finton's
turn
right well that came down to the wire
that end game
um that david had against hafu that was
literally the closest they can possibly
be in the chess game so
he's shown that halfway is not
invincible but i'm sure she's learned
the lessons from that match and she's
going to apply them here
and come back stronger than ever yes
and if easy with aces is unsuccessful in
his task but it is going to be a
a brutal fight then maybe we rely on the
efforts of
xqc who will then have the last group
matchup
against itafu potentially unexpected
potentially overlooked
but it could happen now i spoke with
finton i worked with fenton a little bit
and we were discussing openings i told
him what i thought he should play
he told me to go shove it he was going
to play what he wanted to play
uh and he said if she beats me she beats
me but i'm going down with a fight
and um wow he did say he's playing the
irish gamut so i guess that's
what his heart desired here
i don't know what that is is that an
opening can i google it i've
no idea what it is i've heard of irish
pawns
as a way to refer to triple pawns
but irish gambit
can't quite put my face maybe it's not a
real thing then is that when you like
sacrifice
maybe it's when you sack a piece and
then take a swig of guinness or
something
so the irish gambit is uh e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6
knight takes e5 whoa
i've seen the four knights the halloween
game but that's a pretty legitimate
opening holy smokes
holy smokes indeed i mean smokes might
be involved if you're playing the move
knight takes e5 but uh
yeah that move is uh supposed to cover
that uh also
he can't actually play this because he
plays the queen's pawn
we have a move does hafu know it's her
turn yeah it's 30 seconds of elapse
don't know what she's waiting for
uh i mean hmm
what is she's just sitting there
i don't know what's happening time back
but she's still not moving
oh we started oh there we go just
looking at a different monitor
oh my god i didn't even know i started
okay i guess
e4 now oh there it is the car con
specialty of easy with aces okay
i don't know we're gonna get a two
nights there it is we're gonna get
bishop g4
this is what this is what he told me he
was gonna play yeah this is what
he played in this against xqc no right
yeah i'm pretty sure he's uh sort of
always played the karo khan yeah and he
plays it well he knows the ideas
oh my god my heart is going he was
inspired by me but i only want to say
that if he wins
um oh wow it was actually easy with asus
who reimbursed hafu on the clock himself
what a gracious moment yes that is that
is very nice
um knight f6 is not the most accurate
right
and oh my gosh she punishes it
immediately
our wow is the work pays off
right okay we've got hoffo on the big
screen
um
d4 playing it perfectly so far
i wonder if she expected him to play
this and she had prepared e5
it certainly seems that way e6 but easy
with isis he's playing a very very
decent car con preparing
to move c5 to disrupt white central
control
this is really good let's uh let's let's
pull this up on the analysis board
this is actually a very high level game
all of these moves are super important
notice that uh he's traded off his light
squared bishop
which means yeah like a3 not that great
because he got c5 coming if he if he
gets c5 knight c6 he is a lot better
wow when he sees it all guns blazing for
aces he knows
exactly what he's doing here in the
karaoke all right yes
i taught him this now i can say it
safely but he hasn't won yet so
uh great move and uh for a player that
that might not be so familiar with the
right ideas in this kind of a locked
structure you could get a really bad
position really quickly you could
actually
be lost if you play something like
bishop e3 right or queen
d1 defending right daniel absolutely you
can not only get forked with something
like d4 but if you lose both of those
pawns if
you lose both e5 and c5 levy and black
gets all those pieces out
absolutely that is not an exaggeration
black could be winning out of the
opening
and easy ways just has to handle this
correctly there's a lot of hanging pawns
even knight c6
should be considered but of course you
can just recapture also
on either square now i know andrei is a
fan of the king's indian and i was
telling him that he could play
this but she would know this is coming
so he could play his backup he used to
play king's indian setups and she
doesn't have a huge amount of experience
at least on the hafu chess account it
looks like
against the structure so i was like you
know you can experiment
maybe go where it looks like she might
be unfamiliar
um in this position you gotta attack
the king's side you gotta play queen g3
queen g7 otherwise it's just gonna be
much worse
you can't afford to lose that e5 bun
without any compensation bishop f4
should also be considered but you just
cannot drop that pawn on this move you
have to defend it you have to defend you
have fruit never mind
get it i forget i said it was like a
nice try that was a nice try i couldn't
even say it properly
yeah well that was we almost got there
um
now andrea you've done how many lessons
with hafu
oh we've done quite a number of lessons
we're actually i mean both competitors
here are dear to my heart because
fenton's also good friends with my
sister they hung out a few times but
i was i was doing a lesson with hafu
when fenton was competing against xqc
and we were watching their games so
uh we we even tried to prepare for this
match but she didn't want to spend too
much time on the opening so
that was your choice here oh wow
oh wow wow um
well i i there there could be some
regrets there right because it's
if finton plays a few more accurate
moves he just has a great position
castling here or a6 attacking this
bishop saying what are you doing you're
gonna take me
i ain't shook yup a6 bishop takes knight
and then
the other knight replaces the first one
uh aces chooses to castle he is playing
correct me if i'm wrong a flawless
opening yeah
so far and you can take the pawn
that's just the free pawn that's exactly
what daniel was saying
now the thing is managed to castle so
she has limited the damage so much she
won't be lost but she will be much worse
with that incredible central control by
black
after knight takes c5 now being down a
pawn
doesn't mean a whole lot the game is
still very open it's open as well
uh because the you know the e and the d
pawns for white have been already traded
your dark square bishop's good your
light squared bishop is going to come
back hit the king
he's got to find 95. for him
and he and there it is wow
so what would you guys say is hafu's
best plan for counter play
king side i mean queen g3 i think she's
got to play queen g3
uh maybe put a rook on d1 the problem is
it's like biting on granite that central
control black has
so solid that pawn on e6 and d5
okay we need to now he's just got to not
do any one move mistakes so if if it's
going to come down to that
her tactics are probably a bit sharper
just from all the play
all the practice he's just got to stay
confident
uh i've been giving a lot of like time
advice to these players you know
your opponent's just as nervous as you
so
don't burn all your clock time you know
just if you see a solid move knight g6
boom
play it yeah also hafu told me she
doesn't normally get into time pressure
so maybe that is something she can use
to compensate against finch in here
so she tries to like play the clock also
not just she told me she didn't have a
single game where a time pressure
was a losing factor when it comes for
someone who wow sorry yeah continue
oh when i i was coaching i'd be like are
you sure you don't want to try some some
blitz games three minutes five minutes
and
she said it was never a problem so
she's also one of the few players in
this field that plays
one minute chess and is like not
atrocious at it
i think she does it for fun mostly but
that's exactly what i wanted to point
out though that's really impressive for
someone who's relatively new to chess to
be able to play bullet and not
lose on time every game speaks to just a
very very good natural intuition
and that's really impressive definitely
so
here it is bishop f4 now there could
have been problems if finton had played
queen d6
instead of the bishop because he would
run into bishop f4 this is not so scary
because you can move this knight
anywhere safe
and your queen protects the bishop as
long as you don't move it
directly in front of your queen which if
he does
he will get a very angry message from me
but so let's if he does end up moving
his knight
so afu at least has the bishop pair what
you recommend that she tries to avoid
trading her dark squared bishop good
question
okay f6 six i would say keep as many
pieces on the board as possible but with
what fenton has to be careful about now
is if he moves his knight from e5 that
e6 pun is going to hang
so he's got to keep that knight cemented
on e5
he did just create a weakness with that
move yes
exactly it's not so easy
she has a deep idea she could play
bishop g3 and pawn f4 i don't know if
that's gonna happen but
whole point being that if you get the
knight out of there like daniel said
you win the e6 pawn you win the game uh
you're right back in it
and this is exactly the type of planning
exercise i was trying to focus on our
last lesson
it was what she struggles with most
finding these type of plans where you
retreat
a piece especially to push like the the
f pawn i remember she was very reluctant
so i'll be very impressed if she finds
it
let's listen into finton why don't we
mr easy with aces
fascinating i feel like there's like
vulnerabilities down here now
maybe i should get this up here
eventually and try and get
this over here to protect this square
this square feels like it could be dicey
but
okay
gotta take with the bishop here
maybe she traded trying to prepare f4
but otherwise i think she knows trading
in that position was not
too good for her um wow if she plays f4
that would be crazy impressive
that would be really nice dude
i feels attacked a little genius and
could definitely be calculating
something that i don't see right now but
all i
see is that we're castled this one piece
is protected
this is protect this isn't protected so
that's like not a huge issue though
because
good luck to getting to it right now
you guys want to listen into ha foose
yeah
yeah let's see what hafu is uh okay well
she didn't she played queen g4 which is
still a good move now he actually is
going to get to play his f5
no i [__] up my puns but
but then perhaps the queen could return
to e2 and attack the bishop again
[Music]
oh rookie 8 now
this is very intense
oh we need seven
all right let's bring this to the board
i mean they are they are locked in focus
i mean we can listen in but they are
literally not speaking yeah
but they are which is which is great
concentration every ounce of effort
queen e7 is a great move
yeah you found the best defense we'll
probably try to activate our rooks
around here
wow this is a this is a a good game yeah
he his whole idea to play f5
is nice he's got to develop this knight
if he doesn't get it
okay i i know what hafu's up to but it
it's not scary and he just needs to not
be afraid because you're not going to
get checkmated here like this right yeah
she's
a big fan of this mating trick which i
told her i said mostly
beginners but i wouldn't recommend
shooting for it because it's
easy to defend against but she does love
the h7 threat
this could get very bad for her because
if she plays something like queenie two
i just clicked the queen so all the
squares beard she plays like queenie two
and finton doesn't panic he just plays
like knight c6
she could end up in a very dangerous
position
absolutely it's hard to find a plan here
too and the time situation
we talked about it she doesn't get into
time pressure a lot yeah but
five minutes is not a lot for this type
of position which you know it's very
hard to generate an idea in
yeah middle game is definitely where she
struggles most too
i think everybody okay 197. please
knight d7 because it's the karo khan
moved
and obviously not a mistake but here
knight c6 more active going into the
center
would have been a little bit better hits
the queen but uh yeah he's on fire
uh still opportunity to blunder that's a
good move
practically speaking that's a good move
threatening bishop takes d7
oh that's a great move wow
he's got to move his bishop now to
defend
the threat oh my goodness this could get
really
he's got to see it if he plays queen d6
for example
yep that loses a piece not only does
he have to move his bishop he has to see
the knight takes d5
potential threat defend his queen with
his bishop either d6 or f6
okay he's done it taking the taking the
knight
wow that is
wow wow wow wow that is very nice
that was a nice trick bishop takes d7
i my biggest thing is i know i work with
finton but
i just want a competitive game like if
if this group
if like the way pacman the way easy uh
vinton aka easy says i want to see xqc
just
start slugging it out with with hafu
bishop takes knight
okay we're gonna get a queen into rook's
end game who we like in here
definitely still black look at those
pawns on c3 and c2
so weak hafu's gotta try to orient
herself against the e6 pawn maybe rookie
one
uh we just see a gigantic white board
now i know i don't know what oscars
is dude don't oh it was like a list
he changed overlays he's in the
professor rumor i don't know where he is
but
that those are some very intimidating
symbols on the whiteboard
yeah food's definitely gonna have to
fight she could try to put pressure on
the e6 pawn but
her doubled pawns and her isolated pawns
she just has so many weaknesses
um by the way b6 blocking the queen's
attack on the pawn in the corner
look at that he's playing fantastic he
came to play today he's got to play
rookie 8 rook f6 or rook c6 to protect
this pawn now
if i didn't know what his rating was i
would guess at least fifteen sixteen
hundreds of ways
so far yep 1500 at least yeah
at least rook d1 she's centralizing
now end games oh it's all about these
weaknesses and that is going to be
it's going to be a race who's going to
get who spawns first
yeah do you guys have any sense how good
finton is in the endgame or
beast i mean you know magnus level
probably
of course i would say more on the level
of farouja i if you're overstating it
levy okay i mean
i would compare it more to you know
ferrugia maybe nepo
okay so yeah right right right good on
the attack
maybe not so good at defending i
understand and rookie seven solid move
queen e5 by what should be considered
creating potential ideas of
capturing on d5 exploiting that
undefended broke on e7
dude if she plays queen e5 rook d5 i
will literally fall out of my chair
so that would be insane yeah rook d2 is
much more practical
looking to double on one of these files
or triple she's looking for the triple
attack
triple stack i was curious what fenton's
plan was with rookie seven
he was trying to double on the e-filer
exactly where is he going with his rook
all right let's see he can also push the
pawn forward which he might forget
like he might just not realize that he
can just
expand his pawns forward and they're all
pretty
happy something like queen c6 would be
good here attacking the pawn on c3 as
well
exactly he needs to now wow
there we have it unbelievable that is
actually outstanding
that is outstanding queen c6 is just a
good game of chess
i mean this is awesome
yeah i mean rook d3 and then he can just
push his e pawn and
that rook has nowhere to go
keeping his five now maybe exactly so
well
i don't think he's gonna if he plays
queen c5 again that that will floor me
because that more or less forces a queen
trade or forces hafu to play something
like queen g5 just
get aggressive
yeah it's you know it's still not easy
for black to play this he steps below
four minutes he's got to keep an eye on
the clock
this might come down to a time scramble
the way it's going right now as close as
this game is we might see an
epic finale in this e5 and he goes other
great moves
simple plan yes very nice he does this
d5 square though
so i i'm assuming the eval bar wants
queen g5 here right that looks like an
annoying move i mean if she sees that
hitting e7
it's game on it is game on
equal time 25 moves in
and she does look at hafu finding this
move incredible
this this could be this could be very
bad here because your pawns are so
expanded
and under so much pressure uh she has to
ah sorry uh easy with aces now has to
find
what queen f6 that might be the best
move yeah queen f6
this could be one of the highest if not
the highest quality game we've seen
in across the pog champs so far i mean
yeah
incredible oh no
no no no oh as soon as i said that one
of them
is doing so well oh that is absolutely
tragic
that is fantastic yeah and that is
oh daniel cursed it the prophet spoke
too
soon oh my gosh i mean you know that
that's the kind of game
you you you look back on you go damn you
know i did my best but
the time and just everything you saw
that the pawn was under attack
and you tunnel visioned it you just
didn't take exactly
but yeah but let's not bury him entirely
hafu still has some winning to do
although once this happens the
floodgates open she can now take on a7
yeah a7 it's like a kid in the candy
stores then you say a queen just goes
back and
i can play like e4 f3 i mean
do something but
wow that's
just for you brutal game huffu side
see if she's feeling the wind which i'm
sure she is but sure sure sure let's go
let's do it
oh she seems really excited yeah she's
still very
focused like up a rook but she's hasn't
relaxed yet we're finding the weaknesses
she is just jumping for joy here i mean
my god she needs to calm down
oh my god you're saying too much in two
little periods i'm having too much fun
with it really
have some respect for your opponent stop
stop making fun of me i'm rubbing it in
i mean jeez
this is this is just disgusting show but
can we please go back to the big boy no
i mean obviously hafu
incredible competitor and they're
putting on a show all right let's pull
up the big screen
uh she is she is clinical i mean to
blunder one pawn like if
if a pawn is what you're gonna blunder
through the course of the game
like what do you say you know what do
you say
that's why chess is such a brutal game
such effort and it
can all be ruined in one one misstep
it's just what chess is
she just i i still had uh
i still had her stream on uh and she all
she said was
my mouth is dry i feel physically ill
and i feel like we can all relate
chest just debilitates all of us it's
why we got bad backs
that's why we got sinus problems all
right maybe that's just me and i'm sorry
which i'm surprised she still feels very
nervous here because she should feel
comfortable up a rook relax
yeah uh finton resigns the game the
queen and the rook is going to be more
than enough and she's got a safe king
which will always go to h2
all right
allows herself an imperceptible smile
wow i think we're going to get another
game in a minute but
what just just what a game
just what a game i what do you say
what do you say andrea i think it was
one of fenton's best games they're just
that rook blunder which i don't even
know i guess it was a tunnel vision that
levy mentioned
but i think who knows i i think there's
very high chances for armageddon
absolutely if he plays with the same
quality um
you know retains calm in the critical
moments we might absolutely see him come
back
he just got to keep keep calm keep his
composure and it seems like
he's just the kind of person to do that
um very graciously resigning by the way
as well not playing until checkmate it's
true
i'm curious if he has anything prepared
for black i mean
for uh i think we're going to see a
baltic game with d4 d5 c4
i bishop f5 gotta get an analysis board
oh
d4d actually do you think this one uh
that's what i
taught to hafu um so i don't know if
she's gonna play that
but i do know fenton i think is a d4
player oh
what is this was this a recent lesson
this was maybe like two weeks ago and we
reviewed it
a couple of days ago as well i see you
see
it's difficult because um
like she's gotten lessons from so many
people and she got lessons from
like someone like peter svidler she
might just listen to him
absolutely as she should you think she's
gonna play the grunfeld defense
oh you know not really but spidey yeah
that was mainly why on
our lesson i didn't want to obsess too
much over over openings because she has
so many different coaches
so we'll see it's tough
it's i'll tell you i have taught a lot
of new york city private uh private
school kids
and it's it's difficult because they got
like eight coaches
yeah exactly everyone wants go cha fu
let's see what she goes for
she's gonna be the baltic all right and
the prophet
i think she does knight c6 and there's
this trap
where what black quickly puts it puts
her knight on b4
and e3 in this position would be a very
bad blunder due to knight before
i think he's going to play bishop g5 i
think he's going to be bishop g5 bishop
he has to stop that threat
is he he normally plays bishop g5 um
yeah wow would be a good move
this is definitely my field i mean it's
not the london but it is a similar to
bit
position so finally a d4 game for me
feel comfortable i like the fenton is
thinking here he recognizes that there's
some minefields and he takes
will she play knight b4 anyway we talked
to
yeah then then white has e4 i think we
mentioned this possibility
yeah he needs to develop his bishop and
i and i think he will he very rarely
plays e3 e3 would be a
bit of a bit of a slip yeah and he does
so
he told me that in our first lesson he
plays london queens again but i was like
that's great just keep doing that like
that's a very solid opening repertoire
i have not talked i agree even though
actually i heard you talking
badly about the london on the last
pogchamp
commentary you were doing so oh yeah i
had to defend myself
and let me again backtrack blame
yourself here right right so so i
i played the london i played the
trumpowski i liked i liked the dark
square bishop going to f1 g5
but i was falsely accused i was
slandered
of teaching all the pog channels
participants to london i am not eric
rosen
i understand we're both international
masters but we're different i promise
right daniel you're a gm absolutely
uh they they don't confuse you with
other grand masters named daniel how
many grand masters in the world are
named
i have played another grand master named
daniel daniel compora
there's also daniel king who is a very
prominent commentator
um and i think that might almost be kids
yeah he is i mean it is luke mcshane
here with a wig advantage
i don't know andrea how's your
impressions game can you do impressions
no
not even well honestly i have no idea
who you guys are even
doing an impression of right now but
everything
you knew nobody heard that you know
let's say international master olivia
roseman is very good at peter lecko you
know
uh peter roleck has been doing a lot of
commentary uh peter
what can you tell us about this position
oh man
uh uh i don't i don't know what you're
talking about no um
i'll save it i'll save it i'll save it
because i feel like we're gonna leave
andrea out of this and i i feel like if
you and i just go kasparov lecko
what's andrea's just gonna feel i guess
i don't watch too many of their live
uh you know who gary kasparov is right
yes
i don't listen to him talk too much but
i'm definitely familiar with his
gameplay
see yeah we'll save we'll save some of
the impressions
well bishop g5 daniel you're uh you're
not going to get a prophet highlight
this bog champs just yet
uh but it's
it's it's still on the horizon
potentially potentially yeah i mean this
is
this is a solid position but big props
to
uh easy with aces he responded very well
to that
tough tricky opening he's gotten a very
very solid position here and he shows
uh ability knowing how to play e3
developing his bishop so
very well done once again he definitely
has the advantage with the bishop bear
i i'm hafu i don't think she should have
allowed the bishop g6 trade
to try to save a bishop make room with
it maybe with an h6
wow i keep saying wow but these players
are really really impressed they are
they are just flat out impressive wait
but i have a question if bishop b7 is 97
here the best move because queen e7 is
there is there a knight d5
i think there might i mean you could
take on e7 allow knight t5
and then shift the queen over but i
think that's very dubious i think you
should take with a knight
if she plays knight takes e7 i i i got
nothing
she might be a better player than me
okay mistakes are still possible she is
still human
though fenton also blundered a rook so
anything can happen
hey well disrespect my my
students our students are battling so
we're both had to add here
uh you did way more lessons with with
hafu than with finton
this is this is territory war what this
is this is for group b dominance
please play knight takes d5 finton
please it's just a free pawn
please don't be afraid of taking free
pawns i mean you can also develop the
bishop here it's
white is still better if you play bishop
d oh he takes the knights oh
no i maybe he just didn't see it
oh i think keem just realized
no you know what the dangerous thing
about this position
is that if she plays that move which she
just played
and now she has a pretty nice attack
yeah this could
get really bad really fast the bishop
can't develop itself because
g2 is going to be hanging
yeah i don't know where he's going to be
able to castle his king's kind of stuck
in the middle
oh my god how are you gonna go into your
lounge and then play a move like bishop
d3
vincent that's really cool though i have
to say that setup is really cool
look at that fireplace
i'm disappointed i mean you go you go to
the fireplace you're supposed to stare
at
the you know the at you know the flames
and cultivate good thought you just
bust out bishop d3 and snap yeah i'm
curious if it was like the mindset
because after
he played knight takes knight he started
talking very rapidly so he may have
realized he missed the free pawn and got
a little bit down on himself
and now everything starts crumbling you
know yeah
this honestly feels like fighting thanos
is what this feels like
that like you you just get something you
know
for for the movie to have like a tense
moment and then just like
done queen takes g2 she's gonna play
rook takes h2
you know one indicator that you're good
is not only your good moves but your bad
moves aren't that bad
and we see here that even hafu's
mistakes are by and large in the grand
scheme of things they're minuscule
let's put up hafu speaking of thanos
let's watch offu
is this throwing i don't know
look at that look at that humility is
this throwing
i know highlighting the best move on the
board
i know she really needs to chill out now
i mean it's getting
my ears are hurting she's very cautious
i take i mean the screaming is just
a good run
it's like when tf blade was like i don't
know dude i was just trying
the feeling is
maybe i can just castle this way i
wonder what she's scared i told her not
to be okay
yep that's that's definitely something
she struggled with at some point she i
think she's gotten much better at that
and here we see he has
okay queen b3 white is still in the game
hold on hold on we still got half on the
big screen he said i don't know and
played the best move i wish my life was
like that
i don't know best move i don't know am i
throwing
best move you're like magnus that's like
magnus yeah
okay yeah it's not like i lost him
earlier today
yeah how could you danya uh losing
horrible
unacceptable i'll get my revenge on him
one day
okay so he didn't see queen b3 he's
playing defensive here okay so now
if i go up if i take
oh she's speaking takes that take he
takes it's not good right
she's skipping his turn that's a new
level of disrespect
you just said if i go up and then i take
i mean does finton not get a move
right no she thinks white doesn't look
good he takes
that's lack of class i mean i go up
disgusting
i can start attacking this one
i feel like i'm gonna throw i mean here
she has many good options she could
castle trade rooks knight before
he's gone rook h1 very sensible trading
a pair of rooks
how does she see everything this is
crazy it really does it's crazy it is
crazy
i was basically going to repeat exactly
what you said leviant that's it i
realized
yeah but i was independently going to
say the same thing
just add a caspar of like accent in
there and chat will love it
but halfway i mean you know hafu really
sees everything you know it's
it's quite uncanny reminds me of myself
you know when i was 12 years old
wasn't he like 25 hundred and 12.
everything was like
formally you know is 2200 but i
realistically knew my
my playing strength you know was almost
as good as hufflepuff
bro you your kasparov is
the greatest
thanks i that's how i entertain myself
in very well like like you see the
shower you know and the yeah when i'm
walking around making food
oh my gosh okay truly be a good chess
player you have to get in the character
too
absolutely i can go there
get it back on the big screen here not
too much happening rook h1 clinical move
there the only thing that could happen
here is that hafu disconnects
she is just playing lights out chess
she's probably gonna play rook h8 rook
h1
and i think it's very unlikely that she
disconnects
but i i'm not
i'm not saying i'm cheering for that
what i'm saying is that's the only way
that i think
finton is going to gotcha gotcha
yeah this is
uh it seems to have gotten a little bit
more comfortable
and a little bit more confident as well
incredible definitely
still not over only two pawns up and in
the grand scheme of things that is a
surmountable advantage but not the way
that hafu is playing right now
yeah a great thing about hot foods many
times when players start winning they
get too confident right and then it's
easy to throw but
she never lets the confidence get to her
she stays focused even
how many she is yeah and this is this is
the tough thing about defending a
position you play e4
suddenly your center falls apart this
knight now has a new target
if she plays knight takes d4 here she
should be in the next
invitational world cup i mean olympiad
yeah this is
somebody said we've got a chat pro i see
this she's up but confused with no plan
she's got a plan she's she definitely
has a plan
she's just saying she doesn't have a
plan i mean oh she always doubts herself
that's one of my favorite emotes that
finton has chat pro
thumbs up yeah like you know
well you should you should check it out
she just takes on e4
uh even if she accidentally blunders
with bishop e4
knight takes d4 she still wins the queen
back
if somehow she doesn't see the [__]
she's going
yeah i think she intends to give a check
on g5
and maybe bring the queen to f6 that
would also be solid and strong
while she's calculating it oh my gosh
she might play knight t4 no she might
play knight d4
that's incredible she oh okay get out of
town
she's really gonna know she was hovering
over it she sees them both
she sees both lines
still a perfectly good move wow
why isn't she playing on an olympiad
team
exactly definitely could she has a
dedication for it
she literally could represent
some some of the players uh incredible
i don't think i've ever seen improvement
fast and i'm not just saying it
really improvement faster than her arc
unbelievable especially if she takes the
pawn right now
which she can still do yeah she plays
knight takes d4
i'm falling off my chair she's looking
at it
yes she is she's hovering over here
they're just so sharp man
drum roll please wow oh my lance
oh my what what did you just say that's
a north carolina expression oh my lands
where'd you pick that up when did you go
to north carolina
well when i moved to charlotte that's
when i picked it up
didn't know that i don't think they
speak like that in charlotte i've been
to charlotte i don't
yeah no not quite but oh my god 45
minutes out of charlotte
and you'll see her that expression okay
kona and there there are some
tactical tricks here for example you can
play bishop takes b7
check and if king takes b7 you can play
queen e4
and hope that now that your queen is out
of danger
you can take the queen for free but
black has queen d5
and your dream is ruined
no room for tricks
yep and the thing is if finton takes the
queen and hafu recaptures
then after the king moves to add insult
to injury there's knight to g3
forcing the trade of bishop for night
which is in black's favor
wow wow this is
this is yeah this is crazy
crazy
what does she play now i'm sorry well
i guess like finton has to decide where
he's gonna put his queen
yeah maybe c4
see yeah c4 is
an interest interesting try he doesn't
have i don't know he doesn't really have
any plan of attack but
i guess just aim towards b7
we could listen into finton see what
plans he's looking for yeah let's do
that
let's listen to fenton yes gets out of
the discovery check and protects this
check square
i don't see like i don't see like a
multi-phase plan but
every time we listen in oh huffy is
gonna have to move her queen
just have a little oversight just forget
about the queen hafu
the prophet has spoken again with queen
c4
yeah that's a good move it keeps some of
the tension on the board i mean it's
just
definitely better than trading the
queens going straight into the losing
game
what about this check
take nope because of this
if we go to the square searching
desperately for any counterplay
that is not a fork rookie one threat and
special takes b7 check that might be the
best practical chance take this piece
i calculated rook d1 but i don't think
he thought about rookie one
it's just a nice move isn't it just
protects against his pawn as well
playing very well i would say oh we're
we're back but
uh rook e1 if rookie one bishop b7
actually happens that would be
astounding that would be the comeback of
the day
yeah i have a feeling the rookie one
hafu would anticipate the
attack on the queen mover king or
something
i perhaps move her own king to b8 slide
it off the light square
yeah i don't think she'll fall for but i
don't want to jinx anything so
yeah it's not like any of us jinxed
anything in the previous game so
okay so there was no rick
yeah now she can get in with the queen
right that's going to be the problem
we need to we're even queen e3 check
yep
and wow
yeah this is uh this is curtains my
friends
uh because if you play something like
king b1
well no i was about to go big brain mode
and suggest
queen e4 and that a classic
motes gambit very nice uh yeah with a
smothered mate
right yes
yeah i think queenie two is is likely
queenie two just the trade
yeah i think well there's many moves
here i mean
she's fully aware of that principle to
trading when you have material
she could also just you know even drop
her knight back to e6 that's also
totally fine
and maybe try to make room to bring in
the rook
this is
she's just gonna watch her clock knight
f5 is an excellent move now notice that
f7 is actually not hanging
because of queen to d3 chat picking off
the rook
amazing the queen is stuck defending
so would would queen up see so here's my
question
obviously she was she's like very much
chill leaning back in her chair um
is is she
seeing that on queen f7 there is queen
d3
i think so yeah i don't think she's too
worried about
the most important defender here leaving
wow okay bishop e4 yeah because if she
saw it wasn't possible well
then that's that's that's that is
brilliant
bishop e4 is losing guys because of the
knight forks
knight g3 and knight d6 i thought as
well right yeah
okay even better even better yeah it's
about gg now
it's unbelievable and now queen takes c4
or knight takes c4 both moves are good
yeah wow
wow okay one last guess one last step
rook d2 queen c7
the only way that a blunder could happen
she's got enough time
she's gonna just play like c6 the
professional move
oh absolutely
i anticipate something like c6 right and
you just see this because the queen and
the rook goes straight down
yep queen and the rook are biting on
granite and she's done it like
look when a player is playing ninety
percent of the moves that like
we are suggesting yeah exactly exactly
he's insane unbelievable
uh i listen i look forward to the
playoffs
i really look forward to the playoffs uh
this
we've had so many different personality
skill levels obviously in the in the
first
in the first go around with pawn champs
we kind of knew we want it's like it was
like golden state
and and and cleveland for basketball you
just like charles barkley said you
pretended you didn't know
but you knew it was going to happen and
in this one oh wow she plays 92 she even
play queen takes rogue
i think she wants to take her with
checkmate i think she's seen it and she
wants to send the king over to a1 first
unbelievable that is
who do you think is going to be hafu's
best competitor
yeah makes sense what is wagga's like
rating right now
he's like 1400 oh wow okay that's going
to be an
incredible match up then he's higher
rated but she definitely plays that
level
and we're it's official we have
checkmate on the board
uh it seems like some
she's had some crazy crazy fights but
she is uh 4-0
she has won every game that she's played
uh we are going to take a quick break
get the players in on the call and have
interviews don't go anywhere
hafu and easy with aces will talk to us
in just a moment
[Music]
so
all right take a deep breath get some
water right
get yourself in game shape yep time to
get ready boys we're playing in 15.
that's right all right thank you for uh
all right well i'm gonna i'm gonna raid
you
yeah any of my viewers who want to go uh
cheer on wagga
go for it um i'm gonna stop my stream
now and uh
and just watch as a as a fan not because
i do kind of enjoy
actually the the process here but i um
i'm literally neglecting a lot of other
things so
i need to go hey man thank you good luck
it was good
right yeah play well even better than
good luck
right yeah i will try to thanks coach
and uh
do your thing man do your thing yes
coach
all right all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
rage you right now uh
wagga mama tv
and uh talk to you next time go
go for it man yeah we'll do a lesson
maybe next week or something or in
between the matches so
um anyway all right everybody's coming
your way
all right beautiful beautiful stuff here
so we'll afk on this screen for a bit
um yes it is time to
chill and uh get ready for our game
got some tournament game coming up here
in pog champs in
13 minutes i'm gonna do what my coach
said get some air
you know stretch my legs a little bit
thank you daniel wrench for the 115
year raid welcome to any of your uh
lovely chess viewers
i've been uh been hyped for this playing
my second game in the group stage
playing against conor today and i hope
not to disappoint
my coaches out there both daniel and
gotham and and now anna anna rudolph as
well who has been coaching me so i'll be
back in a second guys i need to take a
short break
and then we have games coming up
[Music]
so
welcome back everybody we're joined by
hafu and
mr finson easy with aces we were just uh
chatting before we
went live uh first of all congrats to
hafu uh
i'll start with hafu actually anything
surprise you about this match anything
you know was the
what were you expecting how did it go
differently than maybe your expectations
uh well people said it was kind of
laming that we agreed upon
our openings but i mean you didn't have
to agree to it
what what no i was i was in he came into
my chat
he came into my chat and i promised no
tricks
yeah we just said nude chicks because um
yeah
so i know you're trying to tell them to
bring something else which would have
been fine honestly
like it's a tournament you can do
whatever you want but he came into my
chat and he's like oh yeah
i'll just play this and this and i was
like okay well i'm going to bring the
baltic and this
and then we can both prep wow this is
very interesting
that's going to be able to rip it open
though i'm not i thought you were gonna
play it differently i watched a small
bit obviously i was drunk but i watched
a few minutes of you and anna
and anna was showing you had to destroy
me and i was just like wow anna's
supposed to be my teacher and she's like
i'm gonna help you
and i went to the follower account
honestly good business decision good
business yeah good business
no no no no no honestly no i'm only
joking by the way amaz anna's so nice
but
you put me under pressure the whole
games and uh i wish
it had ended slightly different than me
blundering the rook but i reckon you're
probably
favorite to win it so i hope you go on
and win it if i don't get to the finals
and that way i can say i lost to the
winner and i'll be happy
thank you played so well actually
um no matter what you prep versus a lion
if you don't have experience first or at
least me i haven't played against the
caracon very much
so even though i tried to study the
lines it doesn't really matter once the
game actually starts
um so i i felt kind of uncomfortable in
the position and you definitely
you were in my pawn structure you had
everything going i think that first game
was yours
um i just got lucky you missed one thing
i don't know i would have been hard
anyway like it wasn't super open and i'm
not great at converting from there but
yeah it would have been better if i
didn't give the rook away i would have
been the pro play for sure
a year the first game was definitely
brilliant fenton that was probably like
one of the best games i've seen you play
we're very impressed i appreciate it we
were every move we were thinking
both of you like played again and again
and especially you fitting in the first
game and
halfway of course the second game was
absolutely incredible
[Music]
daniel went on this big you know
monologue about how it was like a
brilliant game and then like you
you pushed the pawn and the next move
i said this might be the highest quality
game ever played at pogchamps and then
yeah and you've under the rock
it's all my fault champs without it
it's it's crazy because the so i'm gonna
ask both of you this uh i'll start with
vincent this time you know you
uh you are right there uh with with
pac-man and you've got a match-up coming
up
so you either make it to the to the
championship bracket or you get bummed
down to the consolation bracket so what
are you thinking right now and you want
to trash talk them the floor is yours
i don't mind the trash talking we'll get
to that in a moment but like i honestly
did see this as a free roll
everybody's been talking about how
strong hafu is and
has been putting in crazy errors
obviously would have loved
to pull off the upset get the win and to
be guaranteed in the final but in the
back of my mind i kind of knew
that i had the next opportunity that's
why i wanted to rip it open real quick
and just get our like
kings into awkward positions but it just
didn't happen like that but i mean
pacman's good as well but i'll should
talk them
i'm coming for you one of us is going to
be in the losers bracket it's not
consolation nobody wants to be there
okay
i hope it's you and i hope it's not me
that was
that was beautiful and and how far are
you looking forward to your games and
then your subsequent interviews
with xcc i believe he called david
pakman white shirt walter
um uh i've never interacted with xqc
i've nothing bad to say about him but
it's more i'm just kind of
scared i hope he doesn't he's scared i
hope he's not too mean to me
but i think he'll do well and i i have a
lot less pressure
since actually he doesn't have pressure
either huh because
it doesn't matter actually that's
that's the coldest shade ever thrown it
doesn't matter for him
but i mean it doesn't it won't work it
won't affect uh like i still get to go
to winners and he still
unfortunately doesn't so nicely
it's less pressure from us that's all
what happens if obviously hafiz is a
strong favorite to beat xqc but if i
beat pacman and me and hafu were on the
same points or if
pacman beats me does hafu automatically
go through because she did
yeah it's there's there's a whole point
system
tiebreaker system um we we i would love
to chat with both of you
like about chess and life and everything
we we have to let you go we
really do wish you the best of luck both
against bachmann against xuc
for the rest of the tournament amazing
performance thank you for the brilliant
games guys
flawless we're gonna take a look
at uh our final match-up of the day you
know what i would love if they could
they just
have a rematch and they just play again
i know
run it back yeah that was incredible run
it back
i mean wow um
amazing we've got wagga mama and connor
eats fans coming up
yep who can anticipate how this
matchup's gonna end
no idea yeah let's take a quick break
we'll come right back
[Music]
um we're getting ready to start
and then we'll play some chess and then
uh
then we'll play some more chess the plan
is to play the chess tournament and then
probably after i'll just be playing some
games i guess or something
um hold this picture
uh of you on your wikipedia page in
pogchamps picture is the same run right
i think it's the same one i think it's
like at least five or six years ago
yeah it's a bit of an old picture i
guess i have a little bit more beard now
you know longer longer hair different
hair
every time you're on the main screen
they show up you you show up the donut
page
well i mean i never know when they're
gonna jump here i just i could be
i could be full screening it's more
beautiful actually
i had gracie's bed here planned for her
to join me but she doesn't want to
support me in my pogchamps tournament i
guess so gracie is somewhere else
but um i suppose gracie will
join us eventually
good luck you got this thank you kister
thank you kester for the
25 months yeah all right well that means
that
guys say your say your prayers it's time
to put you guys in the mode only mode
you know
you guys are about to get a mode only
and uh i'm gonna mute the uh
notifications too sanja lang
take my 500 bits earlier by the way i
don't know if i actually caught that
when i got raided as well
thank you for 500 bits and uh yeah
i'm gonna mute the notifications now and
then it's time to go
uh go get ready to play
i'm ready man let me plea
all right what's your what's your
favorite emo chat show me
you're in a mode only now so show me not
not multiple mods here you have to go
what is the best emote on twitch that
you have access to
best general one you gotta work
hard here
yeah headache lord for you too no no
writing i know you have vip
but you gotta you gotta make sure to not
write
it's it's uh more time baby rage
the mangle the brain emotes
yes yes yes
a bulldog what the [__] i know there's
no way a bulldog is the best and what's
on twitch shut down
we can do better than this we can do
better
welcome back everybody pog champs it is
our third match of the day
and we are once again looking at group d
wagon mama
vs conor eats pants last minute last
second if you will replacement what are
your thoughts
let's uh let's let's let's try to get
hyped up for this
well thank you today is conor's birthday
so i want him to have
a good birthday we're going to cheer him
on regardless of
comparing their experience obviously
wagga mama
top one of the top players connor
learned chess in 30 minutes
and played austin and that's it so it
was gonna be very interesting matchup
yeah and and i do see a lot of uh phil's
birthday man's i
i do think it is connor's
birthday i actually don't even have to
think it's connor's birthday we're about
a
robot his 21st birthday really
yes very exciting day best day to play
this pogchamps match
wow um is daniel muted yeah
i mean oh my god i was muted sorry
no i was just saying i was just saying i
think i have a suspicion of uh what
connor might be doing after
the puck jams for his 21st birthday but
you know
i'm i'm not wow just expand
celebrating by the way uh oh
by by dropping 20 subs sam
happy birthday wow that is that is very
kind of
of chess
21st birthday that is the last exciting
one that is what i said on stream today
unless in the states you hit 25 because
then
car insurance is cheaper rentals man
you can go partake yes it's
it's dada i'm 24. i haven't celebrated a
birthday in like five years
the math is off there but yeah i was
like yeah
second decade i was i'm good close
enough
game on 15 minutes i wonder if conor did
any prep he he wanted to schedule a
lesson today but
we were obviously i couldn't because of
commentary so i don't think he was
coached by anyone else but
he has improvement then it's work he did
on his own
i think uh i think connor
got a coaching potentially from
danny wrench oh wait no that was wagga
mama who right here yes
was getting coaching from none other
than danny wrench
i'm gonna talk about that because that's
not that's crazy he really needed that i
think i don't think he would have won
without
connor that particular brutal opponent
opponent b5
low-key is a move here it really is
actually
that's actually incredible that it's
like a very legit move
the idea is to play against c4 and maybe
play bishop b7 i'm very scared what
conor's next move is
are you gonna eat your words well
connor's eating some pants but
you guys might eat your words who is
this guy in his last games he he kept
playing bishop a6 so hopefully
i don't know if he analyzes anything but
maybe he won't go for the same idea
change it up with the bishop b7 that'd
be nice to see
one of the benefits of having the
analysis tool unlocked on chess.com is
that if you ever do play bishop a6 once
the computer slaps you upside the head
and hopefully you change your habits
he's deep in thought here uh
this is in london
represent only person in the field that
i showed the london
he's solid he's a down-to-earth humble
chill guy and he plays chill openings
all right
it's not a terrible move but yeah let's
kind of hem in that bishop on c8
why don't we go take a look at wagga
mama's stream just see what he's
thinking about this brilliant opening
technique from his opponent
well he doesn't have much to say about
it maybe he thinks it's prepared
doesn't think it's abnormal i don't know
whoa
h5 will you go levi first
i was going to say that i had a
i had i had a russian coach when i was
like 10
and he used to tell me that if i ever
was gonna practice chess on the internet
i had to do it
right i couldn't waste my time and he
told me he's like you know one time i
had the guy he played like
h5 b5 and he said to me in the chat
you are surrounded so i resign
because i'm not dealing with just
garbage so
you know if conor types to wagga mama
right now you know you're surrounded
all conor needs is the russian accent
and the trash talk
exactly the moves the knights just are
flowing from his fingers
knight a6 son of knight could be left i
would like to see knight
c6 defending long enough it's really
going for the the side of the board
development i don't think we got to
opening principles in our lesson where
plane you should attack in the centers
what makes you say that
andre i mean it's clear that he's
adhering to all of the opening
principles you're right
all the good ones at least exactly just
very original
i like the style of play now he's got to
get his bishop maybe d6 would be
a sensible move but for someone who's
learned chess like five seconds ago he's
actually not playing that badly
yeah he's definitely improved from his
game against austin
okay another relatively sensible move
um he there's this funny well funny joke
i don't know about
funny as a stretch but it concerns uh a
story about one of the first world chess
champions
uh josero capoblanca the story goes that
capable
was giving a simultaneous exhibition so
he was playing
you know 20 games at the same time and
nobody gave him trouble except one guy
who was playing incredibly well on the
entire game
capoblanca ended up winning capoblanca
after the game says
you know sir you played so well but why
didn't you move your knights the entire
game
and he says i haven't gotten around to
learning how they move yet
what so wow
that was spellbinding it's just you know
conor's particular way of playing
reminds me of that
because he's only moved the knights yeah
he's a genius undercover here
i hope i'll be i hope he remembers how
to castle
because i i we had to sneak that in last
minute and i don't think he casts on his
last game so
let's see
this should be the bishop yeah knight
takes bishop
i don't know if conor is going to move
his bishops one of them can't move
uh the other one can go to b7 you should
play in the center obviously
yeah really you have no idea what he's
gonna play next i
i wish we could listen and see what he's
thinking in that genius head but
i don't know thinking about his next
meal of levi's
and i don't know a single other pants
brand
what really
i mean oh no guys we got he dropped his
rook
no i told you i could not call what he
would play
i was really scared that rook h6 was
gonna i was gonna say guys he played h5
is he gonna play rook h6
and uh we were talking about that
earlier right that tendency to do that
do you think we're gonna get knight e5
f6 bishop g6 checkpoint oh
that would be brutal oh my goodness or
is wagon
queen queen takes h5 i know queen either
way
that one
i mean for whack is level oh okay all
right he's following the principles
pushing you know very solid player very
sensible
i think the london system is definitely
a good choice for a player like him
i agree thank you yeah i don't know who
taught him that
let me take him some guy
oh no whoever taught him to london is
garbage but i mean like no complete
garbage yeah yeah the opening itself is
got the coach
right okay
so i just heard we're not listening and
we don't have to listen in uh
all he just said was i don't think that
austin and connor are as strong as the
mountain now i don't understand why he
has to be so toxic
uh that's completely uncalled for it
right i'm just that's we're we're just
joking we we're trying to
get oh no i just looked back at the
board his pawn
i thought he was gonna see it well he is
developing his bishop so oh no he
blunders the other knight
bishop d7 bishop a6
yeah conor is not doing too well
yeah he might be left without any pieces
miss the 95
idea so maybe he'll miss this fork his
tactics could be dull
he has the highest tactics rating by far
of any participant
well then why did he see 95. he's just
trying to play in the center
you know he's trying i guess fun oh i
take that back levy
okay you know highest tactical rating
i'm gonna add something but that was
tactical but he doesn't see bishop takes
b5
yeah i don't know just have a
sponsorship deal that needs to extend
the showtime a little bit
i i don't know you know because the
truth of the matter is that
conor is coming in right at the last
second right and
he he hasn't had a month to prep not to
mention the fact that let me just go to
wagon mama's chest.com profile
real quick yeah wag has been playing
chess for
two years two years wow at least that's
serious
two years versus 30 minutes
that's pretty close i mean yeah yeah i
don't know
i don't know why you think that'd give
one person an advantage
you're right how dare i make that
assumption
well that's right so this should be fine
too bad that the tactic is still
possible but guacamole doesn't see it
he's just not noticing that pawn yeah he
he might not be noticing it
like i said it also could just be a
matter of you know let me
it is more beneficial for my opponent to
actually play some moves
and get the experience of a game
going going forward wagamama as far as
i'm concerned is
top one top two in this field in terms
of favorites if we're gonna pick
somebody who is number three in your
opinion
um oh i would say from yesterday what
was his name
played like a beast uh don't know the
names of them
uh he i do i just say his username is
grypic scripts
ah i say number three i'm gonna have to
do a pacman
pacman yeah i think if he has a couple
more lessons with
you know his terrible coach you actually
might i mean
his game against hafu his games against
that were really impressive actually so
um i think he's got that upward momentum
going for him
pakin's very good but can be a little
bit solid and he doesn't listen to me on
openings advice mr pacman if you're
watching
please listen to me on opening advice
yeah he really packs his packs his
pieces and
oh god no shower i'm sorry all right can
we just kill
dania's cam yeah please do and and
please just turn your faucet on
and wash off after that oh god yeah
one thing i noticed about wagon mom is
he's just so absorbed in like the
opening principles and
all these slow developing moves he
doesn't really pay attention to these
tactics it might be a weakness in his
game against
um when against huffu
yeah i like oh they actually did turn my
camera
oh
that's hilarious that is my punishment i
accept my punishment
honorably that is what i deserved
that's okay i do remember during the i
am not a gm speeches championships there
was there was puns galore
brought the heat and uh
you uh you really [__] you followed suit
no puns puns are good everybody needs to
bring their own style
commentary what's next do you guys think
conor saw bishop takes b5
because he did defend it
i think he wanted to make the longest
queen move possible potentially
i'm gonna say that he saw it i'm gonna
be a crowd have a proud moment for
connor
again the same can be said uh
for conor as it can be said for austin i
i get that they're beginners and i get
that in a group pairing when they're
paired against someone like wagamama
you look at it you go come on how are
you going to watch this this isn't you
know this is not entertaining
uh it's really about both their
personalities them streaming and at the
same time
once it gets down to it the championship
bracket will have
wow yeah what a move from conor oh my
goodness i don't know if he realizes
upon can't take but
if he sees that actually killing it like
this yes
he he saw that the pawn i'm assuming he
saw that the pawn couldn't take the
knight
because ruth takes queen doesn't even
work
though right i just realized that i
didn't even calculate all the way
all right still i have a feeling the way
wagga mama has been playing
he's really not engaging in any of the
tactics i think he's going to move his
queen back to p1
i think he's going to buy it i don't
know
and yeah this is time for him to really
hit himself in his tactical strength
i've never predicted a move before
if if he does not take the knight then
conor like just forced the bishop trade
take the c3 pawn
if he had a little bit more experience
he could actually defeat guaga but
i guess thinking you guys want to listen
in
sure let's do it i voted one if he
calculates
oh he doesn't think out loud
yeah wagga is not like the other players
we're observing like
thor hafu that show the lines they're
thinking about
all we have is this blue dot so
yeah he has this eye tracker software i
think we just go here
oh but no he drops the bishop
oh my god that's the worst version of
that underperforming
yes absolutely wow yeah
everyone was saying our 1800 tactic
level but
dude ah this is a good attack by him i
shouldn't have moved my queen to
c2 in the first place she had no
business being there i actually allowed
his um
his knife to do something his night was
useless here
can he go here with a rook this this is
some this is some hostility here
my goodness from from andrea i'm
disappointed i just
i i agree i i'm siding with andrea
applications for wagga
i really wish conor could just defeat
him but even like winning a bishop it's
gonna be so easy for connor
blender because he hasn't played very
much i wonder if he sees it and
he's smelled a rat or something he
thinks guacamole has something up his
sleeve
i know i think as soon as connor sees
that bishop he's gonna just
i'm taking that well if he played knight
takes before
seeing that the pawn couldn't take the
knight because that
of this i would exp oh oh
the wrong thing i heard the capture sign
i was like yes and then i looked
no it took an a2 oh no
no no and the game chat every single
700 watching just starting to criticize
conor
the interesting thing about game chat
sometimes is that the player is lower
rated than the player playing
and still trash talking them so
yeah knight takes d3 there was a free
piece and then the knight could escape
via f4
and you would be good well yeah i mean
conor for his level has been playing
pretty well this game
i don't know maybe forgot the points of
the pieces
but no i think i made it very clear you
have to remember the pawn is worth one
so
i don't quite know yeah maybe so maybe
he wanted to take on a2 and
i don't know he forgot you know the
queen used to move only one square
diagonally back in the ancient days so
maybe he you know that's what he was
taught
yeah the night taking is uh very
clearly connected with a one square
queen diagonal move
oh absolutely it is all just i told you
what did i tell you
i i was all right
yeah and he's uh he's he's played
queen takes a2 have you
have both of you heard of the steps
method
no what is that i think so but yeah can
you remind me as well
there's this book i don't know if it's
it's originated from the netherlands
or somewhere in europe but it's
essentially
like a learning manual that starts with
step one step two step three
it's very useful for scholastic teaching
but it's also
good for adults adults have the same
kind of learning pattern as far as chess
goes and phase one is always the
material phase
you see you take a capture you just do
it
my dad used to coach his chess club kids
with this actually
interesting so there you go yeah so i
feel as though conor needs an extra
an extra step i can start it soon and
then he will be
completely fine now he had pretty pretty
good
instincts i mean from 30 minutes of a
coaching and then like not really any
game experience
unless you practice on his own time he
definitely has good intuition
yeah we've seen some incredibly fast
learners in the pogchamps
honor among them who who are the other
fast learners
i mean i think i think of course hafu
has to be pointed out
uh yeah and i admit i'm a little bit
biased when i say this but from the
previous spock champs charlie and
david pakman i mean a lot of people who
you know they also do their own thing
apart from chess and they're still
able to carve out time i'm always
impressed when these streamers are able
to carve out time
and they embrace the challenge when it's
it's really not easy when
they're all very good at something else
and to fully
embrace it and uh you know
and be ha and have that mentalities i
think very admirable
yeah it definitely makes me very happy
to see like for example finton
poker is his main thing and he was like
completely absorbed in the game when he
was talking
you're doing game analysis in the
interview it's really great to see that
they're so talented at one thing and can
be interested in chess like this
what are you guys sound today i'm
talented just chess
i'm talented at snoozing my alarm i'm
good at just chatting you know
or just chatting stream over here
that that seems like bait and i'm gonna
avoid it
i'm gonna focus on the game
that was we're lucky we're on emote only
that was oh my god that was like
breaking the fourth wall
it's just andrei just shot out jokes
i know but oh my gosh that was uh
that was that was i liked that that was
good that was fiery i'm just
joking all right
connor's time management also do you
guys think he's gonna lose on the board
or lose on time first
i don't know i don't know i hope he has
a good
a good continue that
a good good one you you're leaving us in
suspense a good birthday of course
did i not say that i thought i thought i
finished my sentence did i not say i
didn't hear you for some reason
oh i'm i'm sorry good birthday yes yeah
you should be sorry
you're not i'm never gonna forgive you
for that you gotta forgive i think we
have commentary together in the future
never no
no okay nope that's it this is the you
you that was the last strike
he took another thing he's really good
at taking and that one is free i mean he
loses in like five moves he's really
good at taking
yes he's really gonna take that was
quite the compliment
and so is wagga mama taking on a7
i have a bad feeling he's gonna drop his
king to d8 sorry go ahead
oh yeah and then there's gonna be
checkmate but i would like to see some
tactical improvement on wagon mama's
side
i do have to say for the
upcoming games okay he didn't walk into
oh well
made it it's not one move at least
he sees it and that is actually very
true especially when you play kind of a
schematic opening
you want to always keep your eyes peeled
there's a temptation to play all those
sort of sort of set moves
um but when your opponent blunders you
want to be able to kind of deviate from
from the main
schematic moves and exploit that so that
i think that's what he needs a little
bit of work on
all right made in one let's see he's
taking his time here
oh i told you i want to see him brush up
those tactics
yeah 100 he should sequin f7
now he's going to lose and i i don't
think white's better anymore
no i i think queen of five
[Music]
i have the window capture of the
chessboard so the eval bar
is completely a shade of a certain color
there is there is no fighting back here
uh wagoman was really strong
but i am definitely going to get on his
case because you got it right like the
guy is
the guy is so strong but missing a
little thing i'm going to get connor
hype
know connor is he popping a white car
i can't tell yeah i think he is
it's almost like it's his 21st birthday
wow yeah almost at least he's
celebratory that's good
when did white claws become so popular
is it been like two years like when did
that happen
and correct me if i'm wrong i think it
started with seltzer water in general
like lacroix and then spin drift
becoming popular and then it sort of
subtly transitioned
into white claw and truly so i think
it's been like a year
i don't know why i'm always all of a
sudden speaking up i'm not pretending to
be an expert on any of this
okay alcoholic we'll just now i know
you're
these kinds of sims that is true
that russians are just the one you know
the one group of people you could always
make fun of like their children and
we both speak as russian jewish men
that's just
that's always there and for some reason
it's always alcoholism but i
only drink claw what is white claw is
american in russia
just claw you know no white claw claw
wait i feel like
uh i feel like russians aren't really
into white claws more just a hard licker
i think that's more of a white girl
exactly the only like club i like i mean
i like white club
am i seeing this right does the bose
says live channel have a white claw
emote
yeah that one's for alex do you i do not
know the joke
i didn't know that actually because she
the joke yeah
she alex has had a fair share of white
claws and
yeah she likes them that's all i'm going
to say
it's like okay yeah they are good
i don't yeah they're only good
in certain environments like sitting on
the beach
yeah of course alex only ever drinks
white clouds on the beach
oh i thought you were just going to say
period i was like what no
that's a bold statement right there not
only on the beach only on your days off
yeah okay beaches i mean i haven't i
haven't been outside of my house in like
seven months i don't even know what's on
the street anymore
knight f3 we've got more chess
look at this look at this man go he's
playing like hyper modern openings
30 minutes in yeah he is comfortable
with his knights
that is his advantage my official decree
is that i i truly believe that alexandra
can coach austin to a top finish
in the consolation bracket and andrea
can coach connor like that is they need
to have a redemption arc
it's just i agree it's hard but it's not
impossible
the same opening but not the way that i
have a lot of
um a lot of potential i think they just
need to put in a little bit of
time yeah
deferred no but i mean given the way
he's playing openings i think he's
already mastered
chess basically yeah i agree honestly
there's not even much more he can learn
to the game
i don't even know if our coaching
sessions will even make a difference
for some reason did he move his camera
what did he do
what what is going on guacamole just
like moved his camera completely and
shifted it on the broadcast
we have a great view of his ear of his
headphone exactly a nice little side
angle of the beard wait guys
did conor train in the same dojo as
austin
the non-existent a4
he's gonna play a4 now then that's gonna
be confirmed
this is watching play a4 this is crazy
rookie one's an awesome move i love it
knight g5 is not an awesome move
it's an austin move that was like a
3 out of 10. it's getting well the thing
is 11 when you start with a 1 out of 10
there's actually no way to go but up so
i have nothing to lose
you you are right that's other than my
commentator position dude
chat likes up let's put it this way
other than my commentating job i have
nothing to lose
and that i've already lost i think after
all the previous funds
knight g5 is uh it's a good move in
atomic atomic being a game mode you guys
can try where
if you take pieces then other pieces go
kaboom
that would win there because the king on
e8 would would be gone
i actually am terrible at atomic i would
keep missing
knight takes f7 in like every position
i i think conor was just accidentally
practicing too much bug house this is a
very famous sack on f7 good for bug
house you're just practicing the wrong
type of chess
bug house of course you get a piece from
your partner you could put it on the
board so then yeah he's waiting for
replacements here
he's going to get uh the knight back in
the center of the board
exactly or
oh i'm so scared i'm sorry otherwise he
is trapped so i hope
he chooses at least the best stack so he
doesn't lose his knight for good
maybe 96 no he does okay and we got the
great bug house strats here
next time we're just gonna tell him what
type of chess we're playing
yeah king takes f7 and now wag is up
there's a4
there it is oh my gosh is he going to
play
there's no way he makes the same mistake
two times k3 rook g3
i'm telling he's basically going to
pre-move rookie no way
no i'm telling you rook a3 next move
let's take bets on that
because beginners only play a4 for one
reason and one reason only and that is
to follow up with rook a3
and they are going to put their head
down and play rook a3 well sometimes he
played bishop
a3 you never know you could be saving it
for another piece
i really hope please please don't do it
no conor will learn from his mistakes
that is quite possible i agree
but something is still telling me
somebody in the game chat said knight
takes f7 is a great move
because it prevents black from castling
and that is one thing
you should probably not learn
a random chat member of the chat uh you
should you know
it's good that's a good strategy in bug
house once again preventing the castle
but
here it doesn't work so well knight is
worth a little bit more than a pawn
yeah well i'm glad that he played knight
f3 he's finally realizing his knights
don't do too well on the side of the
board
it was a6 that's a deep move that is a
very prophylaxis against knight b5 maybe
he was afraid conor would sacrifice his
other knight on c7
right yeah conor's to play knight take
spawn make no mistake right
the one thing he really needs to avoid
is pushing out that e pawn you don't
want to give up the queen whatever you
do
yeah we have to we did see that happen
oh my goodness
okay i am relinquishing the profit
designation to international master
rosemary tater job and your profit roll
for you are you getting to retire
for the for the jokes you know because
we know we know we know connor we know
austin
uh they they have you know they have
sense of humor
and that is one of the reasons why when
we like sometimes watch their games when
we see them make mistakes
we show them a little bit would be a
little bit sarcastic but
i really am cheering for them to get on
the grind
and make it back that's because they got
a killer
in their in their group but the
consolation bracket they have real
chances if they learn an opening
and some checkmate patterns you see i
think with uh conor's last move he mao
slipped he meant to play a bishop g2
attacking the queen but accidentally
just a little bit to the right he missed
that is yeah absolutely now it's
possible
something like rouge g3 rogue g1 he's
got to get his rook out of danger
uh don't go all the way down everything
is covered there so
one of these two moves the only way to
prevent losing a rook
right in the if when they do have a
rematch carnivorous awesome and there we
go
there's your k3 which rook shall we take
he doesn't oh
sensory overload sensor exactly
i think he's gonna take one and then the
other yeah yeah bishop takes a three we
did say that this was impossible
and i'm worried conor is not gonna take
back the bishop although that might not
even be the best oh he does okay
and here comes the other one now if we
get takes takes and then queen g1
that's that's the easiest for wagga uh i
would imagine that conor does take
because
captures are the easiest thing to see
i've been saying that like captures in
general
when you are a beginner it's just the
first thing that you play you just take
and then you figure it out
yeah he hasn't registered that spot in
the
step manual or whatever it was called
what was it called
one step steps okay
yeah how do you say step when it steps
central like there's a huge difference
between i know
not to be confused with step which is a
completely different thing
yeah that's like a mountainous no it's
like a desert region
and there it is making short work in
this game is wagga mama and he goes 2-0
yeah this is uh a clean win for wagamama
and we will get the players in i know we
will definitely speak to nicholas
uh not sure i'm assuming we'll also
speak with connor
quick break last interviews of the day
coming up
[Music]
so
welcome back everybody for our final
interview of the day
we have uh wagga mama aka
nicholas connor uh gentlemen thanks for
joining us
just also we probably should start with
the winner but first we should say happy
birthday
to connor thank you thank you happy
birthday god happy birthday connor
you celebrating with those claws yeah no
after i lost the first game i was like
well
all right it's still your birthday
uh look um we are all chess players well
as far as the commentators go uh but do
you have birthday plans
after this because i know that just
might not be i do
i've got dinner with my family and then
i'm gonna do a stream of uh
uh pokemon snap on that nintendo 64.
fun i'm like that sounds better than
this i know we're on chess
but i can't really go out with friends
right now
so wait why not oh
and uh so wagga mom
mr wagamama um i i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna bust your chops a bit
you were doing a lesson before this with
danny wrench really
i mean connor connor just joined man's
just getting up his basics what are we
what are we doing are we getting
i mean it's but it's not it's not a show
match levy it's a tournament
i know i know you play tournament you
gotta you gotta prepare for a tournament
i thought i was going to have a lesson
with ludwig before but ludwig forgot
so then he called me and i missed his
call um so then i didn't get a lesson
guys connor we'll have lots of love it's
okay um you have good chances in the
consolation or what bracket is he going
into
constellation right yeah yeah yeah
uh but actually not mathematically
speaking i
don't know how to get into the logistics
of it all but uh i i did want to point
out
while we have the board up uh around the
middle of game one conor you were
winning for one move
really yeah yep that's what i was saying
dude
you so you jumped in here with this
knight and
you saw that you know if
uh if he took you you were gonna take
his queen but actually nicholas you
could have taken
yeah i saw that quickly between the
games i was
uh i missed it and here
instead of knight takes pawn ultimately
just
taking the free bishop and for a moment
it would have been
it would have been it would have been
tense because this night comes around
and
maybe the game goes on but yeah
i just i just kind of pull out random
ideas that i know like
aren't like the most normal just to see
if i can throw them off because i don't
i don't know
like all the advanced techniques so i
just try to kind of do weird stuff
since i don't know too much and hope
that it pays off by throwing them off
you definitely threw me off sir there
you go
is there someone in the field
that you are either of you are looking
at next so for example
your next round opponents uh nicholas
you're playing against
uh you're playing against austin awesome
yeah you're playing conor's playing
against um
half tour but beyond that constellation
bracket
champions bracket what are we looking at
any you maybe you want to call out
trash talk thanks to everybody today
all right i'll pounce at the opportunity
of saying
if i do end up playing any of the league
players i would challenge them that if i
win against them they have to play dora
and if they win against me they have to
play league
or the other way around so i have to
play league they have to play dota if
if we lose that is a standing invitation
if i play against
tf blade and gripex but that's more for
the playoffs
okay all right how about you connor yeah
i'm just happy to be here all right
what a good attitude well i'll play
anyone
[Music]
i i think uh i've been saying this both
about
your chess and and austin as well i
think if you
both go back with with andrea alexandra
get like another hour hour and a half
you'll be good to go
and the redemption arc can start in the
um
uh in the consolation bracket i mean
yeah i feel like i got like a
head that works for the game like i get
it like i know people that i can't
really understand it but like i see it i
can see the board and understand what's
going on
we we really liked your instincts
especially having learned as chess
as recently as you did you found some
really cool stuff so
you've got the basics going for you a
couple more lessons you'll be uh you'll
be crushing it
yeah connor i was going to ask did you
practice by yourself at all since your
game with austin or
because i actually saw a little bit of
improvement so then it's just
good instincts yeah i didn't really
practice very i i've been practicing for
the twitch rivals for fall guys so i've
been so busy priorities
well i have so much going on this week
it's okay fall guys is very complex i
understand you should take more time
and i knew that this game like someone
told me that this was like getting my
hardest game so i was like okay
i'll take it as i can and then get a
lesson between my next game
probably yeah we'll get him next time
don't worry but you had really great
instincts i i genuinely thought you
practiced a little bit by yourself
so just downloading the game in my head
yeah yeah practicing in your sleep there
is for sure a learning curve
uh when you when you're starting out and
uh connor uh we wish you the best before
your next match against half tour uh
nicholas same
same with you you better win the whole
thing uh i don't know
i'm calling it i i see a lot of people
saying that but i think everyone's
jumping the gun on it
yes i want to see i i am i'm an unbiased
commentator but i would like to see
versus
i heard ikaru and others say that i'm
that i'm the favorite or something but
and i want to call out one thing hikaru
said i'm one of the
og chess players in the tournament i
want to say
i played a dozen chess games before
pogchamps
in total in my life so i i don't want to
say
that i'm an og chess player but i
watched content yes
i like watching and uh your 10 minute
videos are very appreciated i'm glad
you're
uploading content okay okay secret
that's that is uh yeah i know i know
said the same uh gentlemen we're gonna
let you go thank you so much for joining
us
happy birthday thanks everybody
[Music]
let the players go and take a look at
what's coming up tomorrow we've got
group c friends what are we what are we
looking at here
we got uh we got dog dog and tf blade
zextro and sin and cutie cinderella
cutie is very openly
uh wanting to win the consolation
bracket yes she is
and the trash talking uh contest
yeah well the two go hand in hand that's
true
but what what are we thinking for this
for this tf blade matchup
it's gonna be an interesting one i'm not
too familiar with tf blade i have seen
dog dog play he's been improving
uh so i'm really looking forward to that
um i think there's gonna be some close
matches tomorrow
yeah dog dog tf blade is is a i don't
have no idea what to say i think they're
both around the same strength maybe 900
1 000 level
uh but that will be that will be an
exciting one
and as far as sex row and cutie
cinderella cutie and i looked at
a few opening ideas today
and i i told her what i think sextra
would play with who knows what he'll
come prepared with
and who is who is on the show tomorrow
i should know this should i know this
yeah i should know this too but it was
commentating we'll keep it a surprise
yeah
no no i'm gonna um yeah i don't i don't
actually it's gonna be someone else guys
it's not none of us because otherwise we
would know that exactly
right maybe we get dandy in here uh
it's been fun we had a we had hafu today
taking on
easy with aces very very tense matchup
potentially the game of the pogchamps
but
we have yet to see uh any any final
words
before we sign off well this was
fantastic
um tons of fun as usual love to see
these people grinding especially half of
it shout out to her and
um and easy with aces that was an
incredible matchup
but andrea any final thoughts from your
end well same here i'm definitely
looking forward to the upcoming matches
it's going to get more intense
obviously cheering for hofu because like
kocher and scissors which i thought made
a lot of progress
also looking forward to see some
progress in students like connor and
austin so we'll see how those brackets
go as well
indeed and i guess the one final note i
should say is that tomorrow
given uh the different scheduling
arrangements we had to make i think we
will start one hour later this is a big
moment
i'm on i'm on the big stage right now
signing off here but we will be starting
an hour later than usual there will be
two matchups
both of them in group c don't miss it i
think everybody's trying to tell me that
he car is commentating
it'll be great see you tomorrow thank
you everybody
[Music]
foreign